[主播] 当你能够自觉穿秋裤的时候，就说明你就长大了。
[主播] 你就该搭配上这个黑芝养核桃芝麻黑豆粉。
[主播] 你就
[主播] 喝上就买了。
[主播] 今天咱们99块8。
[主播] 买到的是两盒，平常我跟你说这一盒是
[主播] 79。
[主播] 今天两盒，还送大家一个冲的杯子，然后再加上一些核桃粉的这个体验装，反正好几样嘛，还送好几样。
[主播] 总共下来是99块8。
[主播] 他们今天
[主播] 要给你点赞，要把你送上十亿。
[主播] 刚才
[嘉宾] 所以说这个没有必要，没有必要。
[主播] 刚才你没来，现在不知道已经几亿了。
[主播] 刚才已经在刷了，已经在这叙事了。
[主播] 现在17,17万人了。
[主播] 17万人还是比较累的，大家放松一下啊。
[主播] 身边刚给大家胡说八道什么。
[主播] 没有胡说八道，我再给大家介绍这个黑芝养核桃粉。
[主播] 介绍的很激动啊。
[嘉宾] 我刚听你想要播到晚上三点是吧？
[嘉宾] 导演。
[嘉宾] 这个诉求反馈一下。
[嘉宾] 就石明老师现在要求工作。
[嘉宾] 你能让他失望吗？
[主播] 不是，你
[嘉宾] 往三点播呀。
[主播] 你们听话一个个都听不到重点。
[主播] 我说那会年轻不懂事的时候。
[嘉宾] 你看石明老师现在年轻吗？
[主播] 往三点去干，往三点去冲。
[主播] 我现在懂事了。
[主播] 现在年轻吗？
[主播] 依然年轻啊。
[主播] 归来仍是少年。
[嘉宾] 少什么年？
[主播] 现在
[嘉宾] 很帅，很帅。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 不敢再加时了，晚上播到12点半就可以了。
[主播] 已经很晚，已经很累了。
[主播] 这个直播间年龄最大的。
[主播] 32了。
[嘉宾] 你知道我们直播间里头，大家
[主播] 尽管看上去，董宇辉可能年龄稍微比较大一点。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 但实际上他比我小。
[主播] 你知道网上很多最早传咱俩亲戚关系的时候，你那几天不是还非要让我火。
[主播] 在这给我拉流量。
[主播] 然后很多朋友就在底下评论说。
[主播] 你们不要说了，宇辉老师那不是故意糟蹋明明。
[主播] 宇辉是明明的表哥啊。
[主播] 他是带他表弟呢。
[主播] 大家为什么会产生这种错觉？
[主播] 前边的都说都是对的，但为什么觉得你是表哥？
[嘉宾] 可能我更像一个兄长一样。
[嘉宾] 嗯，我在自己活起来之后我没有忘记你。
[主播] 对，这是这是其中的一点。
[嘉宾] 掌心如父啊。
[嘉宾] 我担心你啊。
[主播] 董宇辉。
[嘉宾] 啊？
[主播] 你咋这么不要脸？
[嘉宾] 我我是不是表达了这种意思？
[主播] 你这个伦理梗啊。
[嘉宾] 你刚说这个，你刚说我像你哥，这是你说的。
[主播] 对，是我说的。
[嘉宾] 掌心如父是不是古人说的？
[主播] 你这个道德底线，关键时候担心你是不是事实？
[主播] 道德底线低可以，但你不能在屏幕前，你这种伦理梗，这伦理到直接
[主播] 这便宜占的。
[嘉宾] 咱俩哥论哥的。
[嘉宾] 镜头我管你叫哥，镜头前你管我。
[主播] 不要脸。
[主播] 哎呀，我这掉了坑可能也掉了有个七八十来回了。
[主播] 但今天这个坑是万万没有想到啊。
[嘉宾] 这关键是你引过来的。
[嘉宾] 我本来没有这个意思。
[主播] 我没有引，但你
[主播] 大家是这么说的。
[主播] 再一个从脸上你让大家去评论一下吧。
[主播] 你老说咱俩长得反正像。
[主播] 不是像，就是
[嘉宾] 很像。
[主播] 都都很沧老。
[嘉宾] 长得确实像我。
[主播] 对，长得都很沧老。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 这个当老师长得老是一个优点。
[嘉宾] 你看做别的这个职业呢，长得老可能是个缺点，但是在当老师。
[嘉宾] 一看就资深，资深。
[嘉宾] 对吧？
[主播] 啊，对。
[主播] 教龄三，教龄30年。
[主播] 大家应该没问题能相信吧？
[主播] 这是退休返聘回来的。
[嘉宾] 教龄30年。
[主播] 大家现在开始冲十亿，冲什么十亿？
[主播] 你能劝一劝他们吗？
[主播] 我刚跟他们说了，让别点了，但是我又害怕大家直接说，你管。
[主播] 我们又不是给你点了，我们是给宇辉点的。
[主播] 管的到宽。
[主播] 你是不是又酸了？
[主播] 又在这干扰。
[主播] 所以我就没敢没没敢特别阻拦。
[主播] 我就说如果是给我点力了就别点了。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] 咱俩在介绍什么，请问？
[嘉宾] 你上来五分钟了。
[主播] 咱俩在介绍什么？
[嘉宾] 不应该想。
[嘉宾] 右下角小黄车需要自己买，咱这个直播间呢，图的就是个开心。
[嘉宾] 不要忘记，不要忘记你的初心啊，你当时是为了卖货的吗？
[主播] 我这心里极度不平衡，今天这此仇不报非君子。
[嘉宾] 不急，你可以等一会反应的时间。
[主播] 今天这个便宜的。
[嘉宾] 你再逐渐进入状态，我已经感觉到了。
[主播] 进入什么状态，我这会憋的都是脏话，你知道吗？
[主播] 我这句都要都要说出来了。
[嘉宾] 但是你角度得找得巧妙，你要直接破口大骂的话，那你就是输了。
[嘉宾] 愤怒就是无能的表现。
[嘉宾] 不能愤怒。
[主播] 愤怒了还咋占便宜？
[主播] 这完了，在这播了五分钟。
[嘉宾] 啊？
[主播] 差点就说出来了。
[主播] 播了五分钟直接降了一半。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 导演说要不一起卖一个锅。
[嘉宾] 要不一起卖锅。
[嘉宾] 可以，咱卖个锅吧。
[嘉宾] 哪个锅？
[主播] 这个锅是吧？
[嘉宾] 来，这个锅是得背啊。
[嘉宾] 你看。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[主播] 你现在给大家说这锅叫啥名字？
[嘉宾] 从业经历啊。
[嘉宾] 这个导演这个锅叫啥名字？
[嘉宾] 导演你倒是翻一下。
[嘉宾] 我都不知道这个锅叫啥名字，多少钱。
[嘉宾] 我们其实面前是有一个提示这个产品信息的屏幕的。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 但是呢，自从我们6月9号火了以后呢，导演也开始不按照这个顺序来给我们排了。
[嘉宾] 他即使排了呢，我也不按着他讲，我在这里自己讲小故事，编小作文。
[嘉宾] 时间久了呢，因为互相伤害，导演也彻底不翻了，甚至现在连PPT展示都不展示。
[嘉宾] 所以大家也原谅我，不是都用不解的。
[主播] 卖着卖着也不知道这个锅叫啥。
[主播] 卖着卖着也不知道这个锅几块钱。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 就像很多人走着走着就算了。
[主播] 苏喂火山盐小白锅。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 火山盐小白锅。
[主播] 不是喂火，哎呀。
[主播] 就是小白锅，小白锅。
[嘉宾] 已经火了，小白锅。
[主播] 小白锅。
[主播] 哎，那为什么是两个？
[主播] 是
[主播] 一套。
[嘉宾] 一个24厘米的，一个是28厘米的。
[主播] 这个你先介绍，你先编个作文，我看一下功能好不好？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 快，你先开始。
[嘉宾] 明明手里拿的这个是28厘米的，年纪比较大，锅也比较大。
[嘉宾] 年纪比较大，锅也比较大。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 主要是油家有口的，需要个大锅。
[嘉宾] 你单身需要个小锅。
[嘉宾] 你看这分配的都很。
[主播] 我但是就不需要锅。
[主播] 要锅干啥？
[主播] 一人吃饱全家不饿，要锅干啥？
[主播] 方便面多买。
[主播] 咱那几块钱的方便面能吃好长时间的。
[嘉宾] 这锅也可以煮面，它的锅身比较高。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 我买一次桶的泡面，那桶的可以用好几天的。
[主播] 你不懂。
[嘉宾] 我输了。
[主播] 好，你说完了。
[主播] 让你编一编小作文。
[嘉宾] 等一会。
[嘉宾] 小作文咱俩在这编小作文有点膈应。
[嘉宾] 你得看咱俩编小作文不舒服。
[主播] 你编不出来就编不出来，你别是拖延时间。
[嘉宾] 那也行，你不是反击我，再给你机会吗？
[主播] 好好，给我机会了。
[主播] 好，那我先介绍好吧？
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 这个锅呢，咱们今天两个颜色，一个是白色的，一个是陶土色的。
[主播] 这个陶土色的，我手上拿的这个大一点是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 大一点的这个是口径是28厘米的，小一点这个是24厘米的。
[主播] 也算是不沾锅。
[主播] 可以当炒锅，可以当炖锅去用，可以翻炒炒菜都没有问题，你看宇辉现在展示的。
[主播] 可以见我们过去的这个同事的视野，都是新东方，都是一家的。
[嘉宾] 大家能理解为什么当年在
[主播] 翻炒非常的好，你让我先把这个功能说完啊。
[嘉宾] 你这个把这甩出来了都，这个姿势就不对。
[主播] 是我没有站着。
[嘉宾] 哎，不是这样甩。
[嘉宾] 你这属于颠簸。
[嘉宾] 我跟你教啊，你看，你要往前送，然后再往回收，看到没？
[嘉宾] 收的那一下使劲，收的那一下使劲。
[嘉宾] 它就这样能够
[主播] 对，论论炒饭。
[主播] 你们是懂的啊。
[主播] 宇辉在做饭这方面比我能稍稍专业一点点。
[主播] 稍稍专业一点点，毕竟是用凉水泡过方便面的比较懂啊。
[主播] 我主要在家里面能煮锅，然后煎炒不太行。
[嘉宾] 往前一送是吧？
[嘉宾] 对，你往回收那一下。
[嘉宾] 哎。
[主播] 对，就是这样。
[主播] 很好学。
[嘉宾] 废了啊，已经学废了。
[主播] 嗯，对，就是这样。
[主播] 你看一个手这样甩着还不累。
[主播] 重量不重啊，1.3千克的一个锅体，两斤六两的，就是让你拿上既不会觉得它特别轻浮。
[主播] 不会像宇辉这样让人感觉特别轻浮。
[主播] 再一个呢，你在甩的过程中也不回特别笨重，然后特别厚重那种感觉，然后都不会。
[主播] 刚刚好。
[主播] 简约大气。
[主播] 然后白色锅身，我觉得其实女孩子的话选择这个可能会更好一点。
[主播] 当然如果一家人口比较多的，建议大家去买这个尺寸大一点的这个28厘米口径的。
[主播] 应该我介绍完了吧？
[主播] 尽量不要用铁铲和钢丝球，这个锅尽量不要用铁铲和钢丝球。
[嘉宾] 送个木铲啊。
[主播] 送个竹铲。
[主播] 或者家里用那个橡胶的那个都可以啊。
[嘉宾] 大家能看到我在颠勺的时候，为什么如此熟悉呢？
[嘉宾] 这就是大学时候的兼职经历。
[嘉宾] 专业对口。
[嘉宾] 大学的时候努力的这个实习挣钱，然后积攒本领。
[嘉宾] 等到这个大四找工作的时候，一鸣惊人啊。
[嘉宾] 你看。
[主播] 你往这来了。
[主播] 这不是老实，这根本都不可能展示的这么顺畅，你看，你看，你看。
[主播] 哎哟妈，哎哟。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 不是你大学的时候去哪了？
[主播] 你不是在兵马俑那给人当解说嘛，怎么又去？
[主播] 还去后厨干过。
[嘉宾] 哎，我还真的在饭店里干过。
[嘉宾] 我有个亲戚，他当时开了一个饭店，大一我回去的寒假没事干，我还在饭店里真的给人干过。
[嘉宾] 啊，擦桌，但是我干的是擦桌子啊，然后呢，这个端茶，倒水啊这些活。
[嘉宾] 真的干过。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 这个颠勺这个可能是属于天赋异禀吧。
[嘉宾] 我在第一次走进厨房那那次，那年我两岁，看见锅，第一眼就动了。
[嘉宾] 拿起来锅，就颠了。
[主播] 这块胡说，这块胡说。
[主播] 我确实跟锅有不解之缘。
[主播] 因为在小的时候，你小的时候你们那村有没有换过那种麦芽糖，我们把它叫老糖，你见过没？
[嘉宾] 梨果糖。
[主播] 你们把它叫梨果糖。
[主播] 我们那换糖的时候，我妈不在家，我跟我弟拿俩家里俩铝锅，换了几块糖。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 从小就与锅结下不解之缘。
[主播] 我都没有站的权利了吗？现在要求这么高。
[嘉宾] 对，你几乎没有了。
[嘉宾] 因为你刚说了。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 一锅糖，然后呢嘛？
[主播] 就拿锅去换了糖。
[主播] 不做饭了。
[嘉宾] 你没有过那种经历吗？
[主播] 但是没有拿锅换过糖啊。
[嘉宾] 石明小时候是有的。
[嘉宾] 我是不要脸，爱吃糖，拿家里锅换成了糖，被我妈追着在夕阳下奔跑的少年。
[嘉宾] 石明老师呢是想吃鸡蛋，拿棍去敲自己家的鸡。
[主播] 我那会真的以朴素的想法，以为鸡催一下就能下蛋。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 我们家那鸡也是六大鸡。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 然后给他关到鸡笼里，我跟我一家的孩子，我就拿一个竹棍根敲，然后催他下蛋。
[主播] 给
[主播] 敲死。
[主播] 董宇辉真的跟锅有不解之缘。
[主播] 刚才讲了拿这个换过糖吃。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 长大这个工作又在饭店实习过。
[主播] 这是跟锅有缘了。
[主播] 他这锅这么这么多年的努力。
[嘉宾] 主要技能就是背锅。
[主播] 也背了一些锅。
[主播] 但是最后还是靠锅火了，那天早上起来拿一个牌子。
[主播] Steak, steak, steak,然后卖那个牛排一个方锅，然后就火了。
[主播] 火的那天就是这样的。
[嘉宾] 你为什么突然说泰语？
[主播] 你不管什么语吧。
[主播] 大家都能记得这一段。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[主播] Steak, steak, steak,牛排牛排12片牛排，然后拿了一个大方锅。
[主播] 每个人都需要锅。
[主播] 宇辉终于找到了自己的那一刻。
[主播] 合适的啊。
[主播] 如果你还没有找到，今天咱们这个是98块钱。
[主播] 大尺寸的118。
[主播] 买一口吧。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 买完了之后呢，大家可以自己家里回去炒啊，蒸啊，炖啊，煮啊都行，但是不建议拿这个锅去敲鸡，因为敲鸡的话鸡会敲死。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 我以为你说是不要拿铲在这个上面咚咚咚这样敲。
[主播] 对吗？
[嘉宾] 不好，敲鸡不好。
[主播] 敲鸡。
[主播] 还是拿棍敲鸡。
[主播] 都所谓，反正都死了。
[嘉宾] 还有300单。
[主播] 还有300单，OK。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 那你敲死之后没有艾玛吗？
[主播] 忘了，反正就敲死了。
[主播] 死了以后呢？
[嘉宾] 我还是很好奇的。
[嘉宾] 啊。
[嘉宾] 来，石明在这，我们先给大家讲一讲。
[主播] 少打听了。
[主播] 社会上的事少打听。
[主播] 行。
[嘉宾] DK搜索百科。
[嘉宾] 听一下石明老师咱卖出呢。
[主播] 这本书我这两天卖老好了。
[嘉宾] 真的吗？
[主播] 真的。
[嘉宾] 学学。
[嘉宾] 那你讲一讲，我听听你是咋讲的。
[主播] 你是文科生，我就是必须得给你上一课。
[主播] 讲一讲。
[嘉宾] 让我长一长见识。
[嘉宾] 听一下鸡子咋敲死的。
[主播] 呃，我先问你一个问题吧，我就是必须给你难住一回。
[嘉宾] 你难住我胜之不武啊，你是理科生，你是李和老师。
[主播] 我作为一个理科，我问你一个文科的问题。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 就是豁出去了，董宇辉，你今天可能就要栽到这了。
[主播] 你准备好啊。
[嘉宾] 我又不是没栽过。
[主播] 别服软，你这么刚上来就不停的示弱，这还能还敢问我？
[嘉宾] 你先问嘛，不应想。
[主播] 你把这个先撤了。
[主播] 好，大家一块回答一下啊，因为我可能前两天讲的时候很多朋友都已经听过了，你们已经知道答案了啊。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 这个知识点呢，应该是属于高中的文科知识，因为我作为理科生其实不太了解，这两天才现学的，然后给大家讲。
[主播] 然后今天，先给大家说一下DK的这一套书。
[主播] 咱们今天是100,188,198。
[主播] 188拿到的是八本，里边呢讲着各种各样的。
[嘉宾] 198。
[主播] 198啊，植物王国呀，比如包括我手上拿的这个气象密码等等。
[主播] 那比非常的好。
[主播] DK是1974年成立的一个出版社。
[主播] 他们家的各种书特点就是有非常非常具有视觉冲击力的这种画面，然后配合上言简意赅的解释的非常清楚的文字。
[主播] 能够让孩子从里边轻松的，简单的，愉快的学到很多知识啊，大概这么一套书。
[主播] 特别适合能够有独立阅读能力的小学三年级往上的，一直可以读到高中，甚至都可以读到大人这个阶段，读到老师都没有问题，很多知识可以一直学下去。
[嘉宾] 经典书籍反复看啊。
[主播] 对，反复看。
[主播] 下面呢，我刚刚开始翻的是这个气象密码的这一本，我就把里边的一些给大家介绍一下。
[主播] 我介绍的工程你要觉得好了，就可以直接去拍起来啊。
[主播] 这本呢，里边讲了天气跟气候。
[主播] 然后呢，它先有一个概数，给你讲什么是天气，什么气候。
[主播] 四季是怎么来的，然后讲了大气层。
[主播] 讲了风，尤其是这个盛行风，还有信风等等这些。
[主播] 再往下呢，有这个水循环，大气中的水循环。
[主播] 水是怎么来的，怎么循环起来的。
[主播] 包括你比如说咱们国家的这个黄河长江的这个源头，它为什么这水能够一直流下去？
[主播] 源源不断的。
[主播] 它是怎么来的啊？
[嘉宾] 因为
[主播] 没有源头活水来。
[主播] 这些活水是从哪来的？
[嘉宾] 太平洋的水气嘛。
[主播] 然后呢，再继续往这边去翻啊，前面讲了这些。
[主播] 我觉得哪是比较震撼的。
[主播] 前面比如说介绍大气层，我给大家介绍这里边比较我看了之后就是有恍然大悟的这些。
[主播] 比如说这一个非常简单的，作为初中生刚刚开始学地理的时候。
[主播] 还不太好理解的。
[主播] 但它这这个图像，你看这个相对位置画的特别好。
[主播] 太阳画到这，然后到了每年冬天的时候，北半球它刚好位置好像高一点，地球呢照到南半球的这一片，然后这就形成了。
[主播] 这个大家能看见吗？哎，能看见啊。
[主播] 形成了极夜，然后夏天到这的时候，你看它在地球在自西向东怎么去自转。
[主播] 刚好光直线传播都能到达这一片，这是极昼。
[主播] 这介绍了四季。
[主播] 四季完了呢，就开始介绍冷空气跟这个暖空气。
[主播] 怎么形成风？
[主播] 这都很简单。
[主播] 热空，地表热的这一部分。
[主播] 就是举这么一个例子吧，这放一盆水。
[主播] 旁边呢是地板。
[主播] 太阳一照，温度升的比较快的是地板。
[嘉宾] 地板。
[嘉宾] 水的比热容比较大嘛。
[主播] 水的比热容比较大，温度上升的比较慢。
[主播] 所以咱陕西人往这种夏天往水泥地上一坐，往铁板上一坐，啥反应？
[嘉宾] 哎呀，狗子烧的。
[主播] 普通话怎么说？
[主播] 臀部具有灼热感。
[主播] 陕西话叫狗子烫的。
[嘉宾] 烧很烫。
[主播] 好狗子。
[主播] 就是是不是这个意思？
[主播] 你稍微合适一点，你不能下就土的土到哪去了？
[嘉宾] 那不雅了。
[主播] 然后继续。
[主播] 然后水泥地，铁板烧的比较高，上面的空气就会膨胀受热，密度小就会往上走。
[主播] 旁边就过来就形成风，风就是这样来的。
[嘉宾] 大概就是一个这样的。
[嘉宾] 形状。
[主播] 然后在基础上呢，因为形成的这种风。
[主播] 那么刚才就是温度偏差造成的，大家看这图，人家这个文字讲的要细致多了啊。
[主播] 这个镜头是。
[主播] 对是这。
[主播] 看这上面有箭头啊。
[主播] 对对对对，就是这意思。
[主播] 上面有箭头，这怎么来的呢？
[主播] 刚才讲那地球上比如说吃到的温度比较高，它两边这温度就低点，那这个风按道理从低温的这个地方往高温这去往这去刮。
[主播] 但刮的过程中按道理它不是正南正北，但你这看这个有点偏。
[主播] 这个偏是。
[嘉宾] 地球带着自转啊。
[主播] 然后形成了。
[嘉宾] 把空气给甩出去了。
[主播] 对，这是一个观点，这就是中间的这一个，因为他很想信风。
[主播] 每年这个时候一直朝着这个方向刮。
[主播] 所以中间的这俩叫信风。
[主播] 然后再往这俩带子呢，刚好又不一样。
[主播] 是这样理解的吧？
[嘉宾] 不是。
[主播] 差不多吧。
[主播] 然后这俩呢是盛行的，一年四季都朝这个方向刮，就叫盛行西风。
[主播] 比如说北半球主要盛行西风。
[主播] 那我现在想问你的问题就是从中国坐飞机去欧洲。
[主播] 你不是经常去吗？
[主播] 下班不是。
[嘉宾] 就也就去过一次。
[主播] 哎，你不是去过很多次下班还去那喝啥啥的？
[嘉宾] 梦里，那一般是梦里。
[主播] 好，从中国比如飞你去西班牙。
[主播] 飞多久？
[主播] 九个小时，11个小时。
[嘉宾] 九个左右吧。
[主播] 我记反正去伦敦飞11个小时啊。
[主播] 假如去伦敦飞11个小时，从北京飞伦敦飞11个小时。
[主播] 回来九个。
[嘉宾] 温哥华飞了十个。
[主播] 呃，咱先不说温哥华。
[主播] 温哥华去飞的话，应该是飞那半边。
[嘉宾] 飞的是做。
[主播] 往西走。
[嘉宾] 白令海峡。
[主播] 对，白令海峡。
[主播] 你这嘛。
[嘉宾] 朝鲜，俄罗斯，白令海峡。
[主播] 咱现在先往这边转，就往欧洲这边。
[主播] 然后飞过去11个小时，飞回来九个小时。
[主播] 啥原因？
[嘉宾] 因为这个它走的路线不一样。
[主播] 路线是一样的。
[主播] 或者说路线的偏差带来的可能是时差上的几分钟而已。
[主播] 是吧？
[嘉宾] 那还有一个是地球的自转造成的。
[主播] 不是自转造成的，跟自转没关系。
[主播] 你跳起来，你落下来，地球自转了，但你还是要落在原来那个位置。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 哎，算了，我不想往下继续了。
[主播] 我这样好像也胜之不武。
[主播] 这个可能多少还牵扯一点点物理内容。
[主播] 那我再问一个。
[嘉宾] 那就是风的问题了。
[嘉宾] 因为飞行速度可能不一样。
[嘉宾] 因为你刚没有说他。
[主播] 你学习的，你学习的过程中主要就是用排除法是吧？
[嘉宾] 差不多。
[嘉宾] 因为两三个选项。
[嘉宾] 来回的路线，不，来回的路线肯定是不一样的。
[主播] 对，主要是风。
[主播] 就是刚才讲的北半球这一节的这个风向。
[主播] 你看这风是自西向东吹的嘛。
[主播] 这盛行西风嘛。
[主播] 你看这箭头。
[主播] 所以你过去的时候它是逆风这样的，然后回来它更多是顺风。
[嘉宾] 所以你这个不一定严谨。
[嘉宾] 因为飞机如果飞欧洲这种一定都是在万米高空，万米高空应该是没有风的。
[主播] 不，有。
[主播] 你不要以为平流层就没有风。
[主播] 平流层的风指的是它更像是这样的，呃，不是说平流层就没有风。
[主播] 这个是很容易形成的一个误解。
[主播] 我们很多时候以为平流层非常的安全。
[主播] 飞机飞行的高度是8000到1万。
[主播] 8000到1万。
[主播] 平流层的这个区域也是。
[嘉宾] 有点出话了。
[嘉宾] OK。
[嘉宾] 来，右下角一号链接，大家可以自己去拍。
[主播] 对，还有很多很多有意思的这个知识，这个上面都有。
[主播] 平流层的这个区域也是
[嘉宾] 那个有点出话。
[主播] 来右下角一号链接啊，讲书呢，大家可以自己去拍啊，对，还有很多很多有意思的这个知识，这个上面都有很详细的一个讲解啊。
[嘉宾] 不影响，可以可以多扯一会。
[主播] 有没有问说你们俩都在这卖了书算谁的？不影响，我们公司也不从来不对主播有要求。
[嘉宾] 对对对对对。
[主播] 卖不卖都行啊。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 还是卖，还是得卖，得卖。
[主播] 但是给大家要把这个说清楚，他们总以为咱们主播之间互相有这种就是大家卖的钱多好像就多一点少一点，其实没有，我们公司不按
[嘉宾] 其实大家看懂以后躺平的样子就理解了。
[主播] 对对对对对。
[主播] 真的不按这个算啊。
[主播] 要这样算天天卷起来，我们这同事关系也不好做。
[嘉宾] 对，卖多卖少其实
[主播] 都不影响你。
[嘉宾] 对对对对对。
[嘉宾] 也就是固定工资。
[主播] 好。
[嘉宾] 固定工资你非要说一下吗？
[主播] 这是好事啊。
[嘉宾] 对吧，我就不焦虑了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 然后呢，你看这是盛行风，他画的这个圈，其实这个风带，它是它是一个圈嘛，你看解释的特别清楚。
[主播] 然后再到这看全球的这个就讲清楚，你把这块的这一片全球的这个风向，当然这块还包括了一些季风，你把这块这半片学完了了解了，你就会看到一个特别神奇的有意思的事情是什么呢？
[主播] 哎呀，我现在有这个高级的了。
[主播] 看。
[嘉宾] 哎，这个在哪买的？
[主播] 这个先不告诉你。
[嘉宾] 咱自己咱咱卖这个吗，导演？
[主播] 这现在不卖，这是因为我天天拿地图讲，我就跟直播间天天呼唤，哪家厂商有供这个，人家拿来先借我用一下。
[嘉宾] 是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 这个挺好。
[主播] 然后呢，大家可以看到，就是刚才不是给你把风向学了嘛，把风向讲了，那从尤其是赤道边上，你看0到30的这一段，尤其是15到30的这个区间啊，在这个区间地球在北半球对应的有哪些国家呢？整个滑过来这里边啊。
[主播] 有从这边可以看到有非洲的尼日利亚，然后有这个几内亚，然后包括了到这边的看差了，这这，度数在这，阿尔及利亚、利比亚、埃及、阿拉伯半岛，你看这些是不是大量的都是沙漠？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 你看，在这个袋子上的都是沙漠，然后包括到这边印度中间其实这一片也是有一些沙漠的。
[主播] 然后唯独咱们中间中国的长江以南的流域的这部分不是沙漠，这个大家比较清楚。
[主播] 你再到这边，看还在这个袋子带状结构上这，包括墨西哥的北边的这，它也是这个沙漠，这边也是沙漠。
[主播] 很奇怪，就是在这个带状结构，为什么都是沙漠，但唯独中国的长江中下游这一片不是沙漠。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 三级。
[主播] 首先这个。
[嘉宾] 对，世界屋脊。
[主播] 首先这个沙漠形成的原因就主要它是因为在这个上刚才给大家看了，它是从两边的风往赤道上刮嘛，往赤道上刮的这个风是什么特点呢？它往赤道走温度越来越高，它就会很干，它不会凝结成水，所以它刮的风是干热。
[主播] 干热就因为一年四季一直吹著这样风，所以在这个袋子上都是沙漠国家，而中国不是，不是就在哪，大家看这个地图这突出来这一大块。
[嘉宾] 是三级。
[主播] 对，世界屋脊，从太平洋这边过来的风被它拦住了，拦住以后形成水气凝结成水，所以这有丰富的水源，就有了黄河、长江的这个起源，源源不断的一年四季往下输送。
[主播] 如果这块突出来的这块没有的话，风从上面掠过去了，很可能咱们的长江中下游今天也就是
[嘉宾] 也就是沙漠。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 大家就了解了。
[主播] 所以这就是从哪懂的，就是这个这块这片突出来的，啊。
[主播] 这个书非常非常的好。
[主播] 它讲了后面还讲了海洋与大陆，讲了气团。
[主播] 你看都是这种图，而且画的很好，我我给大家不夸张的讲，这里边很多的图对应的这些讲解其实是比
[嘉宾] 是吧？
[主播] 教材上有些画的更加清楚。
[嘉宾] 这个图画的确实好。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 坦然承认。
[主播] 讲了气料，我觉得这是很多高中初中地理上学的丰富的知识，孩子从四年级就可以开始读了。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 这是包括后面的这个水循环啊。
[主播] 然后呢，我不能一直给大家讲这本，所以我那天晚上回去大概翻了一下，我不知道你喜欢给大家讲哪一本啊。
[主播] 你可能对人体比较感兴趣，你是不是喜欢这个？
[嘉宾] 我对这种石头植物。
[主播] 石头。
[主播] 你喜欢讲矿石是吧？
[主播] 然后呢，我那天还给大家展示了这个植物，也特别特别有意思，啊。
[主播] 我再给你普及点物理知识吧。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 然后大家把这个书拍一拍，188块钱八本，平均下来一本20块钱，啊，这么一个价格。
[主播] 我觉得植物这本也特别有意思，因为我小时候不是在农村长大，天天能接触到各种，但是很多儿时农村叫的那个名字跟它学名不一样，有时候呢造成一些我现在很想念的这些东西找不见名字，再找不到回来的样子。
[主播] 你看它从根茎叶各种区分。
[嘉宾] 出198。
[主播] 198,198,198。
[嘉宾] 八本。
[主播] 198八本。
[主播] 比如说我问你一个问题，你看这花，人家这写了一个问题，说色彩鲜艳的花朵吸引著传粉的动物。
[主播] 你觉得你看大自然五彩缤纷各种各样的花朵，特别多，你见过黑色的花朵吗？
[嘉宾] 没有。
[主播] 你听过吗？
[嘉宾] 黑色的有有黑色的花，就那种深色的，但不是纯黑。
[主播] 你你听过没？
[主播] 比如说。
[嘉宾] 黑色的没听过，但确实是有深色的花。
[主播] 你咋的没见过就算了，还能没听过，肯定有，但很少，而且它可能就像你说的，它也不是完全纯黑的，那为什么呢？这么多各种颜色的咱没有黑的呢？
[嘉宾] 因为黑的不显眼。
[嘉宾] 它要吸引它来授粉。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 还有它太吸热了。
[主播] 这是这是，对对对，你你还可以啊。
[主播] 说的很清楚。
[主播] 一个是因为它不显眼。
[主播] 没有人来给它传粉的话，它的生命就很难就继续下去了。
[主播] 再一个是黑颜色的吸热，像夏天我俩这样出去，他穿一个黑颜色的短袖，黑颜色就能把各种光都吸进去，而白颜色的呢，就把所有的光都反射出去了。
[主播] 所以你夏天穿一个白的会比较凉，穿一个黑的就会很热，那么你如果是一个黑色的花朵，你这就属于自杀了。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 你把所有太阳能量就是就自己把自己烧死了，自焚了嘛。
[嘉宾] 差不多是。
[主播] 就延续不下去了。
[主播] 所以这个世界上有的11二种黑颜色的花朵，其实都是在北欧的这些地方，黑色郁金香什么的。
[主播] 但其实它也不是完全黑的，它只是比较靠近黑色，啊。
[主播] 它要在阳光照射没有那么充分的，你像吃到附近当然不能有完全这种纯纯的黑的，那指定是存活不了的。
[主播] 再比如说你看这个讲了根系，跟著毛啊什么都介绍的特别特别清楚，我跟你说我看到这个突然看饿了。
[主播] 看到一个泥土的这个根特别看饿了，看泥土的味道。
[主播] 你小时候有没有吃过一个就是在沙里边挖的那个叫鸡大腿？
[嘉宾] 没有。
[主播] 你没见过？
[主播] 就是一个根，它那个茎咬起来甜甜的，很好吃。
[嘉宾] 小时候特别在山里挖的那个。
[嘉宾] 我们去春天去地头拔过一种像毛毛草一样，长出来是毛毛草那个，春天拔出来它咬著有一点点甜味。
[主播] 不是不是。
[主播] 就是还没长出来那个毛毛草，我拔过来。那个根长得像一个鸡腿一样，突然变粗一咬起来那个根很甜，叫鸡大腿。
[主播] 但是我实在不知道它的学名叫什么，所以就搞不清楚了。
[主播] 你再翻两页啊。
[主播] 你看蒸腾作用。
[主播] 就是大自然界，包括刚才讲的风的流动，它要依赖大自然给的能量。
[主播] 植物的蒸腾作用，它也依，不是大自然给的能量，是太阳给的。
[主播] 所以地球上所有的这种动力学运动的所需要的能量全都是来自太阳，太阳能给的。
[主播] 包括植物的蒸腾作用。
[主播] 你想。
[嘉宾] 热带雨林。
[主播] 它要把根系的水分一直吸到那种大的乔木30米50米高，整到那个树顶上，它得需要多大能量，这些能量全都是来自于太阳，整的这个往上吸的蒸腾的的力量啊。
[主播] 好，大家可能听不了这种科学的，想听你用换一个角度讲讲。
[嘉宾] 讲讲。
[主播] 讲讲那个什么给整一下。
[主播] 我刚才有人说要听你讲人生。
[嘉宾] 没事，你先讲，你先讲。
[主播] 好，这是这这是叶子。
[主播] 然后你看到这块。
[嘉宾] 你现在都挺喜欢这种知识类的。
[主播] 光合作用，光是怎么形成的，看太阳光七种颜色。
[嘉宾] 赤橙黄绿蓝靛紫。
[主播] 对，青蓝子蓝靛子。
[主播] 然后呢，植物吸收的时候，它会把跟它颜色一样的光反射出去。
[主播] 把跟它颜色不一样的光吸收进去。
[主播] 那你说植物喜不喜欢绿色？
[嘉宾] 不喜欢。
[主播] 不喜欢，对。
[主播] 因为它把绿色就反射出去，如果你给一个植物，你你回去把你家的那个花盆，给上面如果套一个绿颜色的塑料袋，这个花过几天就死了。
[主播] 因为绿颜色的塑料袋把阳光的七种颜色的光一过滤，只让绿光通过了，而绿光植物那个叶子又把那个绿光给反射出去了，它就没吸收，就自己把自己饿死了。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 哎，所以套一个袋就就挂了，啊。
[嘉宾] 有朋友问这个多大孩子能读。
[主播] 再给大家解释一下啊，独立阅读能力的能读的，就是九岁到十岁可以开始，一直读到高中毕业都没有问题。
[嘉宾] 当然家里有比九岁还小的孩子这本书能不能买？
[主播] 嗯，那就要父母可能带著给读一读。
[嘉宾] 可以。
[嘉宾] 你现在拿他翻一翻，等到他过两年他自己看，你再有嘛，对吧？
[主播] 对对对对对。
[嘉宾] 早买总比晚买好。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 总之是能用到的。
[嘉宾] 金明明退下吧。
[主播] 马上马上马上啊，马上走。
[嘉宾] 让明明讲，让明明讲。
[主播] 然后那个。
[嘉宾] 正好现在20万人，让明明多讲一会。
[主播] 好像没多少本吧。
[嘉宾] 没有了，还有800本。
[主播] 只剩800本的是吧？
[嘉宾] 把这800本讲完吧。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] OKOKOK,明白了啊。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 这是这是我给大家介绍的刚才一个矿石。
[主播] 你又想讲的矿石的点吗？
[嘉宾] 我我不讲了。
[主播] 然后刚才那个气象密码还有这一个植物王国就给大家介绍到这啊，下来剩下的让宇辉给大家介绍啊。
[主播] 你来讲吧。
[嘉宾] 好，我们正在给大家介绍的是DK的搜索百科这一套系列啊。
[嘉宾] 其实我们为什么要让孩子去观察这些天体行星、花草树木、鱼鸟飞虫，还有呢。
[嘉宾] 这个甚至包括这些岩石呢。
[嘉宾] 其实通过大量的观察，看石明老师刚给大家讲解了那么多细致的小的知识，其实很有意思。
[嘉宾] 就是你会发现这个过程中就极强的培养了孩子的好奇心。
[嘉宾] 好奇心、求知欲、想像力，我认为这三个是一个家人能给孩子留下最宝贵的东西。
[主播] 对。
[嘉宾] 爱因斯坦说过一句话。
[嘉宾] 说比知识更重要的是想是想像力。
[主播] 想像力。
[嘉宾] 对，我我我记得应该这句话是爱因斯坦说的。
[嘉宾] 然后如果说大家对于好奇求知欲或者好奇心最强的一个人，那大家应该都听过这个画过蒙娜丽莎那个人。
[主播] 达芬奇。
[嘉宾] 读达芬奇传你会发现他从小长大就是对一切都充满了好奇，他看到什么他都好奇。
[嘉宾] 所以很多时候因为孩子想知道，所以他自己去查资料，自己去查网站，查到最后，他可能就会成为一个领域的专家了。
[嘉宾] 好奇心对一个人成长特别重要，你看他们研究了很多最后事业有成的人，发现他们在成长的过程中，包括成为成年人以后，他还有很大的好奇，他们有时候把这个叫幼态持续。
[主播] 哎，我说的童心就是这个意思。
[嘉宾] 对，一直能够保持这么一种好奇，然后去探索，去追寻，啊。
[主播] 你看大家都在说明明别走，啊。
[主播] 明明想讲可以再讲一会，没事，你接著讲。
[嘉宾] 然后呢，刚才我们提到了好奇心，其实就是要促进孩子对一个东西感兴趣，并且在他感知好奇心的时候，激励他更多去探索。
[嘉宾] 然后最好你知道，由你给孩子讲，最终变成孩子给你讲。
[嘉宾] 因为他都知道一种学习法叫什么学习法？
[主播] 我插一句，有个朋友说他老婆不拿手机点赞，他已经把他老婆扔出去了。
[嘉宾] 把接回来。
[嘉宾] 快点。
[主播] 他生气了。
[主播] 这样很危险呀。
[主播] 你这样有点过了。
[主播] 努力了多少年，一直成了了一次又一次的兄妹。
[主播] 我特别想问一句，你究竟有几个好妹妹？
[主播] 然后这好不容易有媳妇的，现在因为不给你点赞，要把媳妇赶出去，你有点太狂了。
[嘉宾] 赶快接去。
[主播] 谢人。
[主播] 好，接著说书。
[嘉宾] 我们刚说那个叫费曼学习法。
[嘉宾] 就是你听别人听的话，你只能可能懂个230%。
[嘉宾] 你自己阅读呢，你能懂个560%。
[嘉宾] 但是如果你自己了解完了给别人讲，你能掌握个890%,当然这个数字在不同的说法中有各有差异。
[嘉宾] 但总之大家都理解一个原则，谁是把高中英语懂的最明白的人？
[主播] 老师。
[嘉宾] 因为他想给别人讲明白，他自己就得先把那个弄明白。
[嘉宾] 对吧？
[嘉宾] 所以我在这给大家，我刚讲第一个点是通过这些小的植物、动物、石头这些东西，天气现象去鼓励孩子好奇心，你就问他为什么叶子是绿色的？
[嘉宾] 哎，最后得出结论，叶子竟然是不喜欢绿色的，对吧？
[嘉宾] 为什么要去看那些昆虫？
[嘉宾] 那最后得出结论，昆虫其实是最后跟人类一样进化出来的生物，只不过它比人类寿命这个历史要更为悠久。
[嘉宾] 刚才是第一个好奇心、求知欲、想像力。
[嘉宾] 第二个就是刚给大家说到了，由被动学习到主动学习。
[嘉宾] 其实就是由听到说的过程。
[嘉宾] 我们以前给大家讲讲说听是说是影响力，像董宇辉这种巴巴说的，说是影响力，但听是领导力。
[主播] 你看孙老师，于老师。
[主播] 他就是听得多，他说的少，对吧？
[嘉宾] 这个说是影响力，听是领导力，这是在管理学里头。
[嘉宾] 但是我们在学习过程里头，听就是被动的，说就是主动的。
[嘉宾] 费曼学习法大家可能听过这个人。
[嘉宾] 对吧，费曼。
[主播] 他就是我们物理上那个费曼吗？
[主播] 费曼物理学讲义。
[主播] 非常著名的一套书。
[主播] 是一个人吗？
[嘉宾] 他是他是什么时代的人，你说的那个人？
[主播] 啊，费曼，我脑子蒙住了，20世纪的吧。
[嘉宾] 那那应该是一个人，如果是20世纪那应该是一个人。
[嘉宾] 然后呢，所以费曼学习法的一个特点就是从听到自己读，从自己读到自己讲。
[嘉宾] 这样一个转变的过程非常重要，各位朋友们，大家知道当孩子大量的自动的开始给别人讲的时候，他自己就绝对成为了一个专家了。
[嘉宾] 因为你发现你想给别人讲明白的时候，你自己是不是基础知识得好？
[嘉宾] 第二个，而且你再给别人讲的时候就讲出了什么，就讲出了一种逻辑感，你会发现成年人讲话都是关于假期安全，今天我说三点，第一，第二，第三。
[嘉宾] 他开始有逻辑性，他就完整了，所以让孩子学会给你讲，啊。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 然后讲一下岩石嘛。
[嘉宾] 讲一下岩石，大家可能都在听这个岩石。
[嘉宾] 讲点岩石，这个书差不多就过了。
[主播] 还还有几本？
[嘉宾] 还有300多本。
[主播] 还有300多本吧，宇辉把这个讲完，这个书今天完了之后估计啊，可能就上不来了。
[主播] 你看卖完了吧。
[嘉宾] 因为这种很可能这种书出版社印的比较慢。
[主播] 已经卖了三天了，三天四天了。
[嘉宾] 大家能理解这种书其实主要成本在哪，第一是纸张，这种精致的铜版纸很贵，如果是印刷的朋友都知道，第二个就是它印刷的这个过程。
[主播] 讲完了。
[嘉宾] 加油。
[主播] 大家让你别走。
[嘉宾] 我一会还得播呢。
[主播] 啊，你晚上还有是吧？
[嘉宾] 对对对对对。
[主播] 好，那你休息一会去。
[主播] 大家让明明休息一会，啊。
[主播] 生产队的驴也得休息。
[嘉宾] 石头。
[嘉宾] 我特别喜欢石头的一个原因是因为他们曾经见证过这个星球的沧海巨变。
[嘉宾] 也因此具有了一种厚重感。
[嘉宾] 它往往是沉默的，但是它却见证了一切，你不觉得这个很很浪漫吗？
[嘉宾] 就像一个非常有智慧的老人，他经历过了很多事情，但他从来不会主动给你讲道理一样。
[嘉宾] 他会听你。
[嘉宾] 所以这就是我喜欢石头的原因，就是我总是感性的把世界万物都抽离抽象出一种一种特点，一种品质，赋予了一种人格。
[嘉宾] 可能是我我自己的毛病，我总喜欢刻意的去这个解释。
[嘉宾] 但是我觉得这会让我爱上这世间的万物。
[嘉宾] 这就能解释为什么我爱明月，我爱清风，我爱星辰，我爱大江大河，我甚至爱野花野草，我也爱著沙粒。
[嘉宾] 身上可以抽象出很多人的特点。
[主播] 还有50本了。
[主播] 没了吗？
[嘉宾] 还有50本。
[主播] 50本，最后50本了啊。
[嘉宾] 之前于老师不是还跟几个特别这个牛的专家他们去过北京的西山嘛。
[嘉宾] 如果北京的朋友大家可以去带带他去看一下，说北京的西山其实是非常好的研究这个地理和岩石形成的一个特别好的地方。
[嘉宾] 就是说那两条缝之间就是几亿年。
[嘉宾] 有时候你听那种时候，你发现你上下两条石缝之间是几亿年，因为那几亿年里头地球进入了低温期嘛。
[嘉宾] 就是给大家所讲的这个低温导致了很多人种和物种灭绝，在那个温度再升起来之后才有了现在这波的高温，地球的高温期。
[嘉宾] 在那个低温期里头，比如说海洋它结冰了，所以很多东西没有办法继续沉积，但到后来冰化的东西之后继续沉积下去，沉积到底，时间长了就成了岩石。
[嘉宾] 那沉积的有可能是什么？有可能动物，也有可能是植物的尸体，那人也是动物，对不对？
[嘉宾] 所以其实从这个角度去说，我们的身体跟石头并无二异。
[嘉宾] 对吧？
[主播] 是。
[嘉宾] 盖啊，碳啊，铁啊，这些东西身体里都有。
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 人身体其实最多的就是碳了。
[嘉宾] 然后再加的就是轻，轻二氧嘛，轻就是水。
[嘉宾] 然后也有铁。
[嘉宾] 我以前给大家讲过，人身体里头所有的铁元素取出来可以组成一个7厘米长的钉子。
[嘉宾] 就这么夸张。
[嘉宾] 当然这些石头的物理性质和化学性质和自然元素类这些，大家感兴趣的话，可以其实是更多去搜。
[嘉宾] 我不是特别专业。
[主播] 没有了是吧？
[嘉宾] 我只是喜欢研究石头。
[嘉宾] 石头有另外一个原因，其实是因为小时候我们那不是曾经有小时候开过金矿嘛。
[嘉宾] 我我记得我特别小的时候，我们家的抽屉里全部放著各种石头。
[主播] 金的。
[嘉宾] 对，就说你捡到这块叫自然金，其实就是它的金子含量比较高的话，那块出来就能弄出好多金子。
[嘉宾] 所以小时候经常我爸会带我上上山。
[嘉宾] 他会带我去观察石头。
[嘉宾] 就特别小的时候，你看我也不写作业，家里以前有矿嘛，他把我带到山上。
[嘉宾] 然后呢在春天去山上摘那个野花野草，然后看那个飞鸟，一个小鸟落在树枝上，落在很低矮的灌木丛上，啾啾的鸣叫，然后在太阳中飞起，消失在春光里。
[嘉宾] 然后山间的清泉奔腾，抓一只小虾米，抓个小螃蟹，很快乐，你知道山上。
[主播] 还是小孩子。
[嘉宾] 对，就很凉快又很舒服。
[嘉宾] 然后我爸一定会去，就是那矿里头会把那些石头，大山深处石头挖出来，倒在那个石堆上，然后他就会带著我去水里头把那个洗一洗，给我说，这个里头含的什么比较多，这个里头含的什么比较多。
[嘉宾] 然后大概他就能说清楚这个石头是怎么样形成，但其实我现在已经记不清了，我没有他当年记得牢固了。
[嘉宾] 但是那个过程充满了美感，这就是我给当所说的，带孩子去观察世界，体验世界。
[嘉宾] 培养他的好奇心、求知欲、想像力。
[嘉宾] 那最终如果他能从说，从听到说了，那这个孩子就开始不一样了。
[嘉宾] 来，接下来给大家带来的是小王子，之前没有买到的朋友，今天可以有多少本啊？
[主播] 今天上了一万本。
[嘉宾] 小王子没有买到的朋友们，今天可以自己去买了。
[嘉宾] 有很多朋友说到小王子已经读完了，收到额尔古纳河已经读完了，收到苏东坡传也已经读完了。
[嘉宾] 读完了之后呢，每个人在小王子这本书里头，其实看到喜欢的句子是不一样的。
[嘉宾] 我们通常喜欢的是什么？
[嘉宾] 说what is essential is invisible to your eye,说真正重要的是眼睛看不见的，只有你用心感受到的东西才是真正重要的。
[嘉宾] 我们都喜欢的重要的句子叫做it is the time that you have wasted for your rose that makes the rose so important,说你在玫瑰身上所花的时间，使得玫瑰重要。
[嘉宾] 我在6月9号活的，我记得在6月10号15号左右的时候，那一天人直播间里有70万人，我当时是说，我说我与这世间上千千万万个男生并无二异。
[嘉宾] 只是因为你们在这里直播间的停留点赞，跟我互动的消息，这种陪伴的感受使我变得不同。
[嘉宾] 所以你可能在茫茫人海遇见我的时候，突然会有啊，董宇辉。
[嘉宾] 所以就是周杰伦的歌词嘛，美的从来不是下雨天啊，美得不是下雨天，而是与你一起躲过雨的屋簷啊。
[嘉宾] 对不对？所以大家想想你们为什么会不断的怀念那个小时候？
[嘉宾] 你们为什么会不断想去看看旧的东西，去交旧的朋友，吃旧的食物？
[嘉宾] 那是因为你所花的时间和回忆让它现在重要。
[嘉宾] 那这本书里头我相信一定都能找到那么一句话，让某一个成年人在深夜里看到之后，潸然泪下。
[主播] 这个。
[主播] 说这事还挺有意义。
[嘉宾] 只有真诚的温情的。
[嘉宾] 这些东西才能够让一个成年人潸然泪下。
[嘉宾] 我觉得这就是一种情感的力量。
[嘉宾] 我前两天也说到了很多朋友们，比如说他们读完书之后，他们会在抖音上跟我发些消息，甚至在我的发的动态下面评论。
[嘉宾] 就评论了很多都是小王子里头的金句。
[主播] 这个。
[主播] 说这事还挺有意义。
[嘉宾] 我们做这事真的很有意义。
[嘉宾] 这两天我说到最多的就是第一个小王子读完了，第二个额尔古纳河右岸读完了。
[嘉宾] 第三个就是苏东坡传读完了。
[嘉宾] 你知道这三个完全是不同的嘛？
[主播] 那两个书间有没？
[嘉宾] 苏东坡传没有了，但是那个。
[嘉宾] 额尔古纳河右岸给大家谈。
[嘉宾] 你知道读完额尔古纳河右岸之后，很多人就说在原本平淡无奇的城市生活里，在
[主播] 书签有没？孙普战没有了，但是那个
[主播] 阿尔古纳和右岸给大家谈。
[主播] 你知道读完阿尔古纳和右岸之后，很多人就说，在原本平淡无奇的城市生活里，在日复一日重复的劳动里头，
[主播] 在那些枯燥和乏味的人情的，回应和任务的执行中，他仿佛曾经将灵魂飘过远方。
[主播] 那有可能是一个明月照耀的夜里，他在自己的窗前泡了一杯这个自己喜欢的水。
[主播] 然后呢，他读著那里头的文字，读到了那月光下起舞的萨满，读到了篝火旁唱歌喝酒吃肉的人们，读到了好像牵孩子的手站在静静流淌的大河边看水鸟飞起，
[主播] 仿佛牵爱人的手站在山巅，然后看遍山红叶。
[主播] 仿佛看到了白雪来临之时，这个整个大兴安岭白茫茫一片。
[主播] 仿佛看到了驯鹿脖子上的铃铛，在清晨的露珠里头左右晃荡。
[主播] 仿佛我们真的踏过那个清晨的露珠，然后呢，看到了地上白白的一层台险一样。
[主播] 就是很多人就感觉读完那本书之后，就是
[主播] 他当然描述的是一个民族的生活的习惯呀，饮食呀，文化呀，甚至信仰等等那些问题，但那些不是真正重要，真正重要的是通过特别简单的文字，
[主播] 给人们传递了一种现实生活中的美感，虽然我从未亲自见证过这一切，但这一切却在我心里留下了深刻的影响，大概就这个意思。对吧，你说你读那一本书就跟在这跟董会听一小时的直播。感受一样吗？其实挺像的。就是抽离开了原来的生活，OK?Like you were transported to a new place in the forest.That was special, OK?We all like it.在二号链接。然后这本书里头，小王子里头，大家也能找到很多的特别喜欢，特别喜欢的句子。呃，我给你找，昨天我收到一个朋友说的是这样子说，他喜欢这样子的。有一天我看见过44次日落，过了一会儿你又说，你知道，当一个人十分烦闷时，总喜欢看日落的。那么你一天看了44次日落，是不是感到特别烦闷？我问道。小王子没有回答。有一个朋友跟我发了这一段话，然后就拍了他城市那个日落，然后连续发了几张图片，他说我连续拍了七天的日落。你看这是非常短的一个消息，对吗？但是你能从他所发的消息里头感受到他最近一段的心情。有的时候语言甚至都是苍白的。当图片加上文字的时候，就非常好的触动了一个人内心。我有理由相信那样的文字是能够传递出力量的，对吗？他能够让我感受到，可能在一个遥远陌生的千里之外的城市里头，有一个朋友他连续七天曾经捕捉过日落。他没有迎来招霞，但是他看见了黄昏。他无法留住岁月，但是他用相机记录下那个画面。我瞬间就觉得这句话前所未有的美。因为在那一刻，我与一个素未谋面的陌生人取得了情感上的共鸣。有一天我看见过44次日落。过了一会儿你又说，你知道当一个人感到十分烦闷的时候，总是喜欢看日落的。那么你一天看了44次日落，是不是因为感到特别烦闷？我问道。小王子没有回答。这一段话就特别的 有有 有感触了。还有一段说，小王子的脸气得发红，接著说，如果有一个人爱上这亿万颗星星中仅有的一朵花，这人在望著星空的时候就会觉得幸福。这是他对自己说，就在其中的一颗星星上，有我的花啊。你你你这一句话啊。这句话像不像是你晚上回家的时候，经过二环，看见整个城市高楼林立，万家灯火中，你想到其中有一盏灯是为你而亮。你瞬间是不是觉得有很美好的？我那天给大家讲就是那次晚上我直播完，晚上已经一点了，我我从这走回中关村我住那个房子里头。我看到了一个中年人骑著，他应该是个代价，因为他戴的帽子穿的衣服，背后写著什么什么代价。他骑著小的这个电动车在路上左晃右晃，左晃右晃，然后唱许威的歌。我在那一刻仿佛看到了一个开心的孩童一般。对吧，他内心其实很烂漫。他很快乐，他甚至有一些这个无忧无虑的感觉。他今天工作可能很累吧，因为他回家都一点多了。而且他可能是因为真的接不到生意了，他才会的家。我们都知道他们的生活状态。但是他很开心的骑著那个小的电动车在路上晃来晃去，晃来晃去，晃来晃去，然后再唱许威。我那刻突然就想到了，这是谁的孩子，又是谁的父亲，万家灯火里一定有一盏此刻仍然在为他亮著。我相信那个家里的餐桌上可能还会炒著一些特别特殊的饭菜。很有可能是他喜欢的那几道。很有可能他吃了这么多年，他仍然念念不忘的那几道菜。我甚至在想锅里还给他温著米饭。我在想孩子可能写完作业已经沉沉睡去了。整个城市都在沉沉睡去的时候，有一个灯火里头为他亮著，餐桌上给他留著饭菜。想的那刻你突然觉得是不是温情了？就是昨天我跟于老师聊的过程中，于老师有一个点，于老师说，董会你不害怕自己知识讲完了吗？我说知识如果讲完了，说明我不读书了。他说那还有你写的很多的文字，大家都觉得很温情，那你害怕害怕有一天你讲不出来温情的文字了。我说如果讲不出这个温情的文字，说明我没有感知力的。
[嘉宾] 但是我们会一直在经历。
[主播] 只要你在经历你就有感知。
[主播] 你知道为什么很多人没有感知力了吗？
[主播] 我举个例子。
[主播] 大家以前有没有做过绿皮车？
[嘉宾] 做过。
[主播] 火车是不是特别慢？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 你在火车上是不是会跟上下舖的人聊天？
[主播] 会认识他们，对吧？
[主播] 虽然他们晚上睡觉打呼噜，这个还还不洗脚，但你对他很有印象，对吗？
[主播] 然后你们甚至会共享一些泡面和火腿肠，对不对？
[主播] 你如果买了橘子香蕉也会给他分，苹果也会给他分，是不是？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 然后呢，你们一起经过这个时候，看过一个车站，哎呀，这是什么地方？
[主播] 那个人还可能还给你讲他来过这经历，对不对？
[主播] 有过那种经历吧？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 你现在坐高铁还有这种经历吗？
[嘉宾] 没有。
[嘉宾] 大家都各忙各的。
[主播] 对，而且高铁特别快。
[嘉宾] 高铁特别快。
[主播] 你上高铁在睡觉。
[主播] 追求速度的人生活都很忙。
[主播] 因为大家太关注速度，太关注过，太关注结果了，以至于没有人慢下来去体会过程了。
[主播] 所以为什么很多时候有人说，我感触不到生活？
[主播] 可能是因为你在
[主播] 你忙的时候当然得忙，但是你在其他时候其实可以闲下来的。
[主播] 你稍微闲一点点，闲到比如就是阳光明媚的时候，泡一杯茶看一本书这么闲。
[主播] 你瞬间就发现你能感触到很多美好。
[主播] 认真的过好每一天。
[主播] 其实就是感知生活，OK?
[主播] 小伙子自己拍啊。
[嘉宾] 还有两三千本。
[主播] 只剩2300本了啊。
[主播] 这个大家拍，然后我下来给大家把这个其他农产品放到面前，好吧？
[主播] 然后没有买到的朋友现在可以继续买了。
[主播] 东方真选自己做的玉米，就是这样一款玉米，让很多的网友们听完了我的
[嘉宾] 加会员，好吧。
[主播] 加会员，OK。
[主播] 来，各位直播间的朋友们，请大家点击屏幕中间这里，这个屏幕中间这里点进去之后是
[主播] 抖音的东方真选会员体系。
[主播] 我们里头是有两张券的，这个券可以用来买我们自己的玉米，香肠，蓝莓原浆，包括我们自己所做的橄榄油，鸡蛋等等这些东西，你是可以用的啊。
[嘉宾] 现在我们券用完了，我们还有会员积分的。
[主播] 券用完了。
[嘉宾] 对对，会员积分，然后还可以再换券。
[主播] 会员积分可以换券是吧？
[主播] 明白了。
[嘉宾] 包括它的点赞，那个看咱们的直播，包括下单咱们的自营品都可以赞积分。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 这个玉米我在第一次卖的，第一次卖的时候我讲了一段那个经历，其实我给大家说玉米其实你买不买无所谓啊。
[主播] 但是我其实希望通过食物让你有一些回忆，或者你你你很自豪的可以把一些食物分享给你的家人吃。
[主播] 其实是不是这个玉米，我不在乎。
[主播] 我不在乎，因为我卖多卖少对我都没有什么影响。
[主播] 所以我就能更放松的做自己。
[主播] 呃
[主播] 这个玉米它很好吃，煮熟了之后那种很软，很糯，然后又有一些淡淡的回甘的感觉，就是让我回忆起童年。
[主播] 我之前讲的是那些无忧无虑的仲夏夜里头，繁星点点，然后呢，我躺在院子里，躺在爸妈的怀里，一个手拿著玉米，一个手还贪心的抱著西瓜，
[主播] 那个时候头也不疼，腰也不疼，也没有失眠，然后你也没有作业。
[主播] 然后呢，爸妈身体健康，爷爷奶奶陪在你身边。
[主播] 后来呢，你离开了那个小的村庄，然后你也在大城市奔忙。
[主播] 你很少再有那样的时间和精力去体会生活中小的这种惊喜了。
[主播] 就即使有你可能也没有以前那样的感动了啊。
[主播] 哎呀，我嗓子刚才有点咳嗽，我把声音先关了啊。
[主播] 丰俭由人啊，这个看自己啊。
[主播] 有朋友说4.5亿啥意思？
[嘉宾] 4.5亿赞了。
[主播] 现在已经4.5亿了。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 哎呀，谢谢。
[嘉宾] 而且一定要加会员再点赞，加会员点赞还有积分。
[主播] 加会员点赞有积分，就是积分他们可以用来买东西。
[嘉宾] 可以换咱们的券，可以换我们的券，然后券可以用来买东西。
[主播] 换我们的券，然后券可以用来买东西。
[嘉宾] 换他们的一些周边。
[主播] 换周边。
[主播] 所以只要加了会员去点赞，他是有券的，是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 啊，明白了。
[主播] 有积分可以换券。
[主播] 点击屏幕中间。
[主播] 你既然愿意点，那你点击这。
[嘉宾] 不要一直点。
[主播] 真不建议一直点，点的干啥吗？
[主播] 我觉得其实更多的，你知道刚才小王子里头那句话就很很很很动情。
[主播] 就是大家为什么在这点赞，大家你真想一想，大家真的是因为喜欢我吗？或者喜欢我们吗？其实不是。
[主播] 其实不是。
[主播] 因为你知道我们直播间这一个夏天从6月9号到今天已经整整一个月了。
[主播] 这一个月里头我们讲过了多少东西？
[主播] 我们从苏格拉底
[主播] 讲到了沙士比亚。
[主播] 差不多吧，从哲学到文学都有了。
[主播] 然后呢，我们从天体行星讲到三餐四季。
[主播] 有吧，从地球到粮食都有了吧。
[主播] 然后我们从师词歌赋也聊到了人间理想吧。
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 我们回忆过童年。
[主播] 我们畅想过未来。
[主播] 我们说过痛苦。
[主播] 我们也说过喜悦。
[主播] 我们在这里大声笑，我们也在这里哭。
[主播] 然后呢，我们在这里唱过歌，然后我们在这里给大家耍过宝。
[主播] 其实这一个月来说，对于很多人生命中是一种极其极其特殊的体验，你懂吗？
[主播] 就是就是很多人很少能够在一个月里头，他的感情体验如此丰富。
[主播] 他跟著先哭几天。
[主播] 或者他跟著笑一段时间。
[主播] 然后又跟著买了好多的书，然后又跟大家分享了很多好吃的。
[主播] 就是其实很少我们会把生命活出这样的厚重感和这样的密集程度的，对吗？
[主播] 其实大多数时候生命是很平淡的。
[主播] 所以我我能，我其实能理解大家现在的。
[主播] 其实很多人是想把那些那种强烈的感动抒发出来。
[主播] 大家有一种极其强烈的纪念感。
[主播] 好像我点一个几几亿的赞，我就能够让我的人生有一个标志性的事件一样。
[主播] 我其实理解你们。
[主播] 但但是我又真的心疼你，因为你点时间久了，手指头应该会难受。
[主播] 因为我以前当老师，我一夏天回孩子们微信回到之后手指头就疼。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 所以我真的心疼你，乖乖，把手机放起来，对不对？
[主播] 听话，乖。
[主播] 放下，放下，别点了。
[主播] 别点了啊。
[主播] 不点了，不点了，没事。
[主播] 你冲那干啥吗？
[主播] 你说呢？
[主播] 你听我说一会儿话。
[主播] 然后呢，你觉得有意思的东西你买一买。
[主播] 觉得有有感触的时候，你其实写一写。
[主播] 你知道有时候我说的山川明月，你却想到的是峡谷的清风。
[主播] 我说的是三餐四季，你可能想到的是直短情长。
[主播] 我说的是天体行星，你可能想到的是大江大河。
[主播] 就是你在听一个人说的时候，你其实往往有不同的感受的，对吗？
[主播] 或者我讲的很多场景，在你看来极其的像死，极其的熟悉。
[主播] 好像真的自己亲自经历过一样。
[主播] 我不知道你们有没有一种感触啊，就是时常看到一个画面或者听，看到一个事情的时候，哎呀，有一种恍惚感，
[主播] 我好像以前见过这个东西，好像我经历过。
[主播] 但实际你是真的没有经历过的，你为什么会有那种恍惚感呢？
[主播] 那是因为你遥远的记忆里头，或者你的梦境里头，你可能曾经想像过那样的东西。
[主播] 那个就叫做缘分啊。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 很浪漫。
[主播] 所以你在听的时候，其实我建议你可以拿个本子，或者你用电脑你放旁边，你听到一些特别有意思的东西，你啪啪可以记下来。
[主播] 这种记录感特别重要。
[主播] 就是为什么人的表达力之间是有差异的？
[主播] 因为你强化的程度不同。
[主播] 我一般在看到一些特别好东西，我会写。
[主播] 写的越多，你就越敏锐了。
[主播] 就像我们说大脑如机，如光二头机嘛。
[主播] 越训练越发达的意思。
[主播] 呃，这个
[主播] 小王子还有吗？导演？
[嘉宾] 小王子还有。
[主播] 还有。
[嘉宾] 873本。
[主播] 只剩800本了。
[主播] 这个前面
[主播] 写著 I ask children to forgive me for dedicating this book to grown up.
[主播] I have a serious excuse.
[主播] This grown up is the best friend I have in the world.
[主播] I have another excuse.
[主播] This grown up can understand everything, even books for children.
[主播] I have a third excuse.
[主播] He lives in France where he's hungry and cold, he need to become comforted.
[主播] If all these excuses are not enough, then I want to dedicate this book to the child whom this grown up once was.
[主播] All grown ups were children first.
[主播] So I correct my dedication.
[主播] 所有的成年人一开始都是孩子。
[主播] 只不过几乎没有人记住他了。
[主播] All grown ups were children first, but few of them remember it.
[主播] 这句话曾经我们还有一个观众跟我私信说，老师，你这个找这个书是不是错了？
[主播] 这个就牵扯到了高中的一个知识点，few和a few。
[主播] a few是有几个，少，比如有三四个，有四五个。
[主播] few是没有。
[主播] 就像a little和little一样，加了a之后就是有一点。
[主播] 去掉a就是几乎没有。
[主播] 刚这句话说的特别好。
[主播] 就是说
[主播] all grown up, grow叫成长。
[主播] grown就已经长起来，grown up是一个合成词，叫做成年人。
[主播] all grown ups
[主播] were children first.
[主播] first叫一开始或者当初。
[主播] 然后这块有个括号说but,那我们在写的时候不用这个括号。
[主播] but few of them remember it.
[主播] 朋友们，如果你今晚想要记住一句话的话，
[主播] 可能一会儿还会讲到很多东西，但是我特别希望你带走其实就这一句，说所有的成年人一开始都是孩子。
[主播] 只不过few叫几乎没有人，a few叫有几个。
[主播] few of them remember it,说几乎没有人记住了而已。
[主播] 所有人一开始都是孩子。
[主播] 只不过没有人记住了而已。
[主播] 没有人记得了。
[主播] 你你看这个其实，我觉得这本书是唤醒人很多内心的美善，对吧，对于生活的感知，对于爱情、亲情等等陪伴感很多的理解。
[主播] 当然还有一个，其实我们在很多时候，不要忘记你曾经有多么快乐，不要忘记你曾经有多么幸运，不要曾经你得到过多少爱。
[主播] 那些会让你走的更加坚定，活得更加快乐。
[主播] 还有一个，比如说我当年是老师，那我就会记得。
[主播] 有的老师只是忘记了自己曾经是学生。
[主播] 你当年当学生的时候，你就听不懂，你就知道那些讲法你是听不懂的，但你当老师之后你还是按照那样讲，然后过去批评说学生你就是笨，你说我教过最差的一届。
[主播] 其实你当年也是学生嘛，你都忘了当年你你为啥听不懂呢？
[主播] All grown ups were children first, but few of them remember it.
[主播] few of them,就几乎没有人了啊。
[主播] 所有人一开始都是孩子。
[主播] 只不过后来大家记不住了。
[主播] 小王子的原句它其实是这个，原版它是英文，它是法文的，因为这个作者是一个法国人。
[主播] 但是呢，这个是一个英文版的，because English is like more widespread, it's like more commonly used, commonly used。
[主播] 用的更加广泛一些。
[嘉宾] 还有不到100本了。
[主播] 不到100本了。
[主播] 他前面这块这一段说献给莱昂威尔特。
[主播] 请孩子们原谅我把这本书献给一个大人。
[主播] 我们给孩子写过很多童话，但好像很少给大人写过童话。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我之前说我说成年男性的童话是武侠小说。
[主播] 那小王子应该是所有人，不管男性还是女性的童话。
[主播] 我有一个正当的理由啊。
[主播] 这个大人是我世界上最好的朋友。
[主播] 所以如果我想给我世界上最好的朋友送一本书的话，我觉得小王子是可以的。
[主播] 我还有一个理由。
[主播] 就是这个大人什么都理解，甚至写给孩子们的时候他也能理解。
[主播] 所以第二个，成年人的理解力特别强。
[主播] 我们通过一些特别简单通俗，甚至一些抽象的语言，他其实能听懂背后的话。
[主播] 比如说你在玫瑰上花的时间才是的玫瑰重要。
[主播] 你生活中为什么会念旧？
[主播] 老房子，老朋友。
[主播] 老的习惯，老的家具，其实那些都不重要。
[主播] 重要的是你在他们上所化的时间啊。
[主播] 对不对？
[主播] 他们见证了你的成长啊。
[主播] 还有我，我还有第三个理由，这个大人现在居住在法国，他在那里受动挨饿，很需要人安慰。
[主播] It's okay to be weak.
[主播] It's okay to cry.
[主播] OK?
[主播] 成年人也是有可以脆弱的，对吧，大家听过男人哭吧，哭吧不是罪。
[主播] 是可以的。
[主播] 你不用非要握紧拳头当一个硬邦邦的成年人。
[主播] 孩子的事里头说，你要握紧拳头，一言不发，然后穿过整座城市。
[主播] 但是我们是人，人也都需要被关注，被帮助，被理解，被呵护，被温暖，被信任，被尊重，被宽容，被原谅。
[主播] 对吧，为什么要一直硬邦邦的做一个不苟言笑的成年人呢？不快乐的。
[主播] 我愿意把这本书献给这个大人曾经童年时他当过的孩子。
[主播] 每个人，每个大人曾经都是孩子。
[主播] 可惜的是很少有人记住这一点。
[主播] 因此我把献词改为献给还是小男孩时期的王莱威尔特。
[主播] 莱昂威尔特，嗯哼。
[主播] 说的多好呀。
[主播] 这本书是没有了，是吧？
[嘉宾] 没有了啊。
[主播] 呃，玉米还有吗？导演？
[嘉宾] 还有多少单？
[嘉宾] 还有4000单。
[主播] 所以刚才接著小王子的那个话，为什么董宇辉在讲到这个玉米的时候会特别的动情呢？
[主播] 其实重要的根本不是玉米。
[主播] 重要的是我们再也回不去的童年。
[主播] 对吧，那些无忧无虑放学之后，跑到巷子里一六一玩一下午的时候。
[主播] 不用担心作业。
[主播] 那时候你也没有手机，也不用担心你几几十分钟不回消息的话，有人开始给你打电话催你。
[主播] 你也很少有照顾的情绪。
[主播] 基本上你生活里犯的错，妈妈或者妈妈爸爸或者爷爷奶奶都会宽容原谅你。
[主播] 然后你身体很好，然后呢，那会儿饭量也好，心情也愉快，无忧无虑，young and carefree。
[主播] 因为小时候家里在北方嘛，就是这个陕西渭南潼关。
[主播] 所以我们那儿就是种玉米的，我记得特别深刻的就是每年种玉米的这个时间里头，其实还挺麻烦的。
[主播] 从玉米特别小的时候，我们就要去地里头去锄草。
[主播] 通关。
[主播] 所以我们那儿就是种玉米的。我记得特别深刻的就是每年种玉米的这个时间里头，其实还挺麻烦的。
[主播] 从玉米特别小的时候，我们就要去地里头去锄草。
[主播] 现在可能很多都是直接喷那个灭草的那个农药了，都不锄草了，是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 灭草剂。
[主播] 那个对人体有害吗？
[嘉宾] 还是有一点。
[主播] 是吧？
[嘉宾] 但是它会随着时间慢慢的会消掉。
[嘉宾] 直到植物成熟的时候。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 我看到现在基本很少有人除了，都是大面积的喷洒了。
[主播] 小时候是要锄草的。
[主播] 而且有的草即使把它锄出来了，哪怕哪怕它都干了，但是只要下一场雨，它的根系再次伸到土壤，它还是会活过来。
[主播] 所以我我记得我小时候锄地的时候，人要一锄头一锄头，紧接着要锄细致一些，甚至把剪看到的石头剪出来扔掉，扔到外面去。
[主播] 把那个杂草，那些特别不容易死的杂草扔到外面去，扔到地头的那些草堆上，让它晒干。
[主播] 我就比较懒。
[主播] 爸爸妈妈呢，一开始就是他们锄很宽的，给我留特别窄的两溜，从这头锄到那头，咱就回家吃饭。
[主播] 我记得他们在那不紧不慢的，然后深深的弯下腰，啊，弯腰，腰怎么这么疼，他们怎么腰能不疼呢？长大才知道，其实他们只是不说而已，怎么可能腰不疼？而且他们应该比我腰更疼才行。因为人的关节磨损是有有有一个积累的量的。我记得我特别懒，我就拿出头，卡，摁在土壤里，然后拖着往前跑。然后我以为我这样拖过来，全部就把地能锄好。然后我就在那捣乱。我爸也不说我。结果后来我锄完了之后，过几天我爸把我叫到地里，你现在看一下。因为你刚翻开新的土的时候，你其实看不到你到底锄了多少。但稍微一晒干，你会发现，其实你只是挖出来一点点土，然后湿的土把其他干的那些地表覆盖了。所以其实第一个你根本没有锄。而第二个你拉着跑的时候，你那个锄头左右在晃，控制不好方向，把很多的玉米苗全部就锄死了。就直接给拉断了，就拉死了，就。所以其他地方都是那个土很松软，然后玉米长得越来越好，我锄那两溜里头，大部分地其实没有碰到，是干的，然后那玉米还死了。特别小时候。所以你要知道它小的时候你得去锄草。长得差不多的时候，你还得给它丢一些化肥。氮磷钾嘛。主要是尿素，尿素是啥？是氮对吧？
[嘉宾] 氮。
[主播] 氮肥。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 因为磷和钾一般都是离地的时候翻进去的，走。
[主播] 然后要补充一些尿素。
[主播] 氮。
[主播] 其实现在有一种更加先进的工具，就是我们之前卖那个大米，有一个微生物技术。
[主播] 你知道这个微生物是能够从空气中捕捉氮的吗？
[主播] 它有固氮、解磷和解钾的作用。
[主播] 就是你你记得小时候撒那个那个尿素那个，撒的时候那个味道特别刺激。
[嘉宾] 刺激。
[主播] 刺激的，其实它就散到空气里了，所以很多时候被植物吸收的很少。
[主播] 所以必须得埋。
[主播] 得用锄头埋住，但我就比较懒，我就不埋。
[主播] 所以最后全部都挥发到空气里去了。
[主播] 现在的微生物是能从空气中捕捉氮的。
[主播] 为什么下暴雨的植物好呢？因为暴雨来得特别快，它把空气中很多氮细枝叶就融入到土壤里头去了。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 然后呢，氮磷钾。
[主播] 我记得后来就要给它上化肥。
[主播] 然后呢，到了这个特别高的时候，长高的时候，有时候它又长得特别密集。
[主播] 你发现两个离得特别紧，又都长得很高的时候，这时候一定会有一个把另外一个给给扛死。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 或者两个其实都长不大。
[主播] 所以我们又得需要第三次东西，就是去那个去书它的苗。
[主播] 哇，那一般都长得特别高了，书那个苗。
[主播] 然后书完那个苗之后就觉得很可惜，它都长这么大了。
[嘉宾] 就还要把它拔掉。
[主播] 然后把那个拔掉之后，每次我妈妈都会让我把那个抱在一起，找一个木架车把那个拉回去。
[嘉宾] 喂牛。
[主播] 因为隔壁的一个爷爷家里有养牛。
[主播] 然后我就把那个拿在手上，一根一根喂那个牛吃。
[主播] 牛都吃饱了，躺下了，我把它用棍打起来，让它继续吃。
[主播] 然后呢，我记得又夏天的那个特别热的午后，别人都在家里睡觉。
[主播] 然后树枝上的蝉鸣声，知了知了知了叫了一夏天。
[主播] 空气里全是燥热，然后呢，几乎也没有风。
[主播] 没有一个人，树叶都晒得蔫儿的下来。
[主播] 然后一个长相奇怪的猴子站在隔壁爷爷家的那个牛棚里，手里提着一筐那个玉米苗，然后一根一根的喂，然后身上全部被苍蝇蚊子叮一身的大包，但是
[嘉宾] 饿死不屈。
[主播] 真的是饿死不屈。
[主播] 就一直在那喂那个牛。
[主播] 一般到了书玉米那段时间，隔壁爷爷都不用出去放牛。
[主播] 因为牛都吃饱了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 他最多是拉着牛在旁边转上一圈，你们就回来了。
[嘉宾] 消消食。
[主播] 对，牛要消食。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 然后呢，就书苗。
[主播] 然后等它再长大的时候就长出了这个，长出了那个
[主播] 玉米的穗了。
[主播] 然后我记得我我一开始小时候就不喜欢去去干活。
[主播] 因为太苦了，太晒了，太热了。
[主播] 而且玉米的叶子边上有个刺，会划破你的胳膊。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 这很疼嘛。
[主播] 疼，然后最后爸爸为了让我愿意去地里干活，他们就给玉米地里种了很多的西瓜。
[嘉宾] 好重。
[主播] 对，就是给那里头种了很多的西瓜。
[主播] 或者种很多的豆角，因为你知道拿豆角去炖土豆特别香。
[主播] 你吃过没？
[主播] 土豆炖豆角你都没吃过？
[主播] 超香。
[主播] 下次去西安了，我请你吃一个那种在风雨口的那种。
[嘉宾] 烤肠。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 你一看就会吃。
[主播] 真香啊。
[嘉宾] 还可以加点咱们这个玉米。
[主播] 还可以加点咱的玉米，对。
[主播] 然后呢，反正我就记得他们就会在那炖。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 所以后来呢，就骗我说地里有西瓜。
[主播] 有时候有，有时候是真的没有。
[主播] 他也忘了他有年重了，或者忘了那个重到活了没。
[主播] 反正他就跟我说有。
[主播] 去了就钻在地里头，哇，天，脸上全部是玉米那个叶子的边，致取状的，把我脸都划破了。
[主播] 再头低头跑来跑去，跑来跑去去找那个西瓜。
[主播] 我现在想一想，其实还是挺有意思的，因为你现在再回忆起来那种，那个过程充满了美感。
[主播] 玉米本身并不重要。
[主播] 是你在玉米身上所花的时间让玉米显得重要的。
[主播] 你说呢？
[主播] 就是因为你要在
[主播] 一开始要去播种。
[主播] 然后呢，要去锄草，要去施肥。
[主播] 要去这个书苗。
[主播] 然后你要等它长大，最后再把它收回来。
[主播] 所以等玉米收回来，磨成了那个玉米粉的时候。
[主播] 或者把玉米打成碴子，妈妈再给你煮的玉米粥，或者蒸的玉米那个窝窝头的时候。
[主播] 你吃着才会有一种特别强烈的满足感。
[嘉宾] 劳动后的幸福感。
[主播] 真的劳动后带来的满足感。
[主播] 我呢给大家讲这个劳动是能够带来人的心理满足感的。
[主播] 呃，托尔斯泰他是一个贵族。
[主播] 托尔斯泰他写了很多的书，但是他到
[主播] 很多人，但他晚年他觉得自己应该被批判。
[主播] 因为他本身就是依靠着很多人的劳动成果去生活的。
[主播] 所以他觉得自己就像一个蛀虫。
[主播] 所以托尔斯泰后来也亲自就去农庄里干活。
[主播] 为什么劳动会给人一种满足感？
[主播] 我前天给大家讲过一个词，除了多巴胺，还有一个词叫什么？
[主播] 叫做内啡肽。
[主播] 听过吧？
[主播] 内啡肽是什么是什么释放？
[主播] 身体有个东西叫做垂体腺。
[嘉宾] 腺是吧？
[主播] 垂体腺。
[主播] 就是在大量的劳动，或者是大量的运动等等，或者长时间的专注性的学习、读书之后，你身体经常会有一种暖呼呼的感觉，有没有过？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 暖呼呼的感觉，其实就是内啡肽在发挥作用。
[主播] 垂体腺在补偿你。
[主播] 它告诉你刚做的是对的。
[主播] 身体在尝试奖励你。
[主播] 它给你一个棒棒糖。
[主播] 精神棒棒糖。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 有的朋友说，董老师真的吗？
[主播] 我为啥一读书就痛苦，一读书就瞌睡呢？
[主播] 那可能是因为你一开始选的书有点难了。
[主播] 一开始选的书有点难了。
[主播] 你从这个简单的书开始读。
[主播] 有朋友说我在减肥，躲过了我妈妈做的晚餐。
[主播] 却没有躲过你的土豆炖豆角。
[主播] 哈哈。
[主播] 特别香的。
[主播] 炖到之后，那个土豆已经特别软烂了。
[嘉宾] 香。
[其他] 口水要流出来了。
[其他] 烤肠也很香。
[主播] 然后那个豆角也入味了，我的天呐。
[主播] 哎，这个烤肠真的很香。
[嘉宾] 哇，超香。我们今天烤肠的规格还是极的，昨天晚上已经卖光了。今天又给大家补了一点。
[主播] 我们自己的烤肠是吧？
[主播] 咱这个是用什么做的？
[主播] 空气炸锅做的？
[嘉宾] 煎的。
[嘉宾] 用平底锅煎的。
[其他] 这个煎的很快。
[主播] 哇，黑胡椒味儿的更好吃。
[嘉宾] 有味道。
[主播] 给你拿一个，给。
[嘉宾] 不要。
[主播] 可以吧，可以吧，这么多呢。
[主播] 吃吧，不要害羞。
[主播] 好东西要分享。
[主播] 你拿一个。
[主播] 肉的纤维感很强。
[主播] 咬破了外皮之后，里头的汁水就在你嘴里头散开了。
[主播] 你们也拿一个，吃吧。
[主播] 很香。
[主播] 调出肉的那个香味。
[主播] 我现在已经大脑停止思考了。
[主播] 然后呢，汁水在你唇齿之间散开。
[主播] 咬的每一口都是惊喜。
[主播] 嗯，尤其你放到嘴里整个嚼的时候，那个肉汁。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 你没吃吗？
[嘉宾] 我旁边的小姐姐每天都要炫半盒。
[主播] 半盒。
[主播] 不吃啊，不吃啊。
[主播] 有个朋友说，说话呢，别吃饭。
[主播] 我不吃了。
[主播] 这个没有焦，它可能是煎的时候，把它给肠衣给煎的有一点点过头了。
[主播] 但是吃的时候没有糊味。
[主播] 嗯哼。
[嘉宾] 我们可能稍微再煎的时候，它大了点。
[其他] 啥呀，就是之前咱老用那个烤肠烤，然后阿姨给咱换了个口味。
[主播] 嗯。
[其他] 对呀。
[主播] 哎，刚咱卖那个瓷的锅能用来煎这个吗？
[嘉宾] 可以啊。
[其他] 可以。
[主播] 可以的，是吧？
[其他] 我再加就是用那个锅煎的。
[主播] 你就是用那个煎的。
[主播] 我有理由相信你吃过它之后，你会很难忘的。
[主播] 因为其实烤肠这个大量的农产品这个行业里头，没有坦诚来说啊，除了育种阶段以外。
[主播] 和养殖阶段，像最终的制作过程中，其实它所需要的成本或者科技含量其实坦诚来说不高。
[主播] 最后怎么样能让烤肠好吃一点呢？
[主播] 你是不是用的好的肉？
[主播] 你要是真的用那种养了300天以上的黑猪肉，人是能吃出来的。
[主播] 你买上不同的几种烤肠之后，你的舌头是骗不了你的。
[主播] 你的舌口远比你想象的聪明很多，你的鼻子远比你想象的聪明很多。
[主播] 材料用的好，大家真的是能吃出来的。
[主播] 这第一个。
[主播] 第二个就是
[主播] 是不是真的安全？
[主播] 那就看你在这个过程中，比如说它里头的细菌的控制的量，你车间的整个的干净的程度。
[主播] 还有不要添加一些对人体不好的那些廉价的那些防腐的东西。
[主播] 其实就是在上面花花时间花成本的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 一分价钱一分货。
[主播] 看你自己。
[主播] 喜欢就拍，不喜欢就不拍也可以啊，丰俭由人。
[主播] 朋友说520是什么意思？
[主播] 啥520？
[嘉宾] 5.21到了。
[主播] 到5.21算了。
[主播] 行了，5.21我已经满足了。
[主播] 行吗？
[主播] 可以吗？
[嘉宾] 520也是爱你的意思。
[主播] 为啥？
[嘉宾] 你快一点读。
[嘉宾] 520，521。
[主播] 520。
[主播] 520，我能理解是，我爱。
[主播] 那0怎么能是你呢？
[主播] 为啥呀？
[嘉宾] 约定俗成，规定。
[主播] 521听起来更像啊。
[主播] 至少你看你一是不是有点像？
[嘉宾] 那我错了，那可能是521。
[主播] 是吧？
[嘉宾] 毕竟毕竟我也不太懂。
[主播] 刻意的。
[嘉宾] 不刻意。
[主播] 补的这句话就显得刻意了。
[主播] 是不是刻意的？
[主播] 还行是吧？
[主播] 啊，我想起来了，对呀，每年5月对，每年5月那几天不是还各种搞促销活动的吗？
[主播] 是吧？
[其他] 什么也没买过，也没事。
[主播] 啊，那我肯定没买过。
[主播] 啊，反应过来，对对对，我知道这个，我知道这个。
[嘉宾] 哎呀，网友说521是比520多爱你一点。
[主播] 521是比520多爱你一点，哎哟。
[嘉宾] 哎呀。
[嘉宾] 赶紧学起来。
[主播] 哎呀。
[主播] 520的那天给他买了一个东方甄选的原味烤肠。
[主播] 我想让你感受牙齿咬破了肠衣之后，那个肉的汁水在唇齿之间散开的感觉。
[主播] 那种惊喜和满足感，有一些让人窒息。
[主播] 就像我那天初次在人群中见到你，紧张到窒息一样。
[主播] 我原本想象过很多种方式见你的时候要怎么说出我心里的花。
[主播] 但我真正站你面前的时候才发现惊喜是没有办法排练的。
[主播] 在5月21那天我给你买了一个黑黑胡椒烤肠味的烤肠。
[主播] 它跟昨天原味的区别就是它的味道是更丰富的一点。
[主播] 因为与昨天5月20号相比，今天5月21，我又比昨天更爱你多了一点。
[嘉宾] 哎哟，可以可以可以。
[主播] 你看，就你们俩刚给我这个信息，我就发挥一个小作文。
[主播] 可以吧？
[嘉宾] 可以可以可以。
[主播] 几个要素要全。
[主播] 把那个一要说进去。
[主播] 还有一个就是你咬破了肠衣之后，肉汁在你的口腔里散开，当时你这种。
[主播] 你真的是一种语言难以描述的满足感。
[主播] 就像见到你的时候，紧张无法排练一样。
[主播] 你有过那种经历吗？在家里对着镜子说了很多遍。
[嘉宾] 但是一见到的时候，就紧张的都说不出来。
[主播] 呀，但你真正站他面前的时候，你紧张的连手都不知道往哪放。
[主播] 你还说按你排练的来呢。
[主播] 真正的行动是不可能排练的。
[主播] 你排练的只是那些文字。
[嘉宾] 在自己喜欢的人面前，你永远都是紧张的，不知所措的。
[主播] 呀。
[主播] 导演什么都会呀。
[嘉宾] 手套。
[主播] 啊，对，我得戴手套，要不然我手脏了。
[主播] 朋友说董宇辉恋爱理论家。
[主播] 理论高度已经拿捏住了。
[嘉宾] 实战家。
[主播] 实战谁会呀？
[主播] 我要会实战，我在这卖菜，开玩笑呢。
[主播] 理论高度家。
[主播] 你知道这就是当老师当很多年之后爱给别人胡讲道理。
[主播] 而且把道理讲的栩栩如生。
[主播] 画龙点睛。
[主播] 哎呀，差一笔这个都活了，你知道吗？
[主播] 一听董宇辉讲，人生全是道理。
[主播] 然后问董宇辉，你过得怎么样？
[主播] 稀碎的人生啊。
[主播] 我胡说八道能行。
[嘉宾] 说。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 书还用吗？
[主播] 书。
[主播] 这三本一会，这四本一会要讲的。
[主播] 徐老师这四本说有吧？
[主播] 你找一找导演。
[嘉宾] 我能找一找。
[主播] 像这种古诗词的书每天都应该卖一次。
[主播] 因为每天都有新朋友。
[主播] 北极甜虾，东方甄选给你带来的。
[主播] 又一次惊喜。
[主播] 哇，今天是新的虾对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 哇，好鲜啊。
[主播] 你给给给你们几个，赶紧吃。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 我过敏。
[主播] 我过敏，所以我戴着手套呢。
[主播] 拿几个给你们吃吧。
[主播] 趁着它很新鲜。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 导演给个近景啊。
[主播] 看一下这个虾身上还沾着这个冰霜呢。
[主播] 冰霜。
[主播] 你没有切镜头。
[主播] 啊？
[嘉宾] 往后拿一点。
[主播] 啊，因为他太小了，不好捕捉是吧？
[嘉宾] 对对。
[主播] 现在呢？
[主播] 这是熟的啊。
[主播] 它从海里头捕出来之后。
[主播] 捕出来之后，就在船上进行了加工。
[主播] 它已经是熟的了。
[主播] 看，已经是熟的了。
[主播] 北极甜虾。
[主播] 我再给你掰开一个，看。
[主播] 掰开了之后，见到里头的这个是什么了吗？
[主播] 细细的密密的在一起，这个是什么呀？
[主播] 它的籽儿。
[主播] 只有三到五年生的。
[主播] 一般都得五年了。
[主播] 坦诚的，三年都很少。
[主播] 因为北极甜虾在小的时候是男孩子。
[主播] 等到四年左右的时候，它会变成女孩子。
[主播] 一开始是少女。
[主播] 然后忽然肚子就全都是籽儿了。
[主播] 不好意思，我今天嗓子不是特别舒服。
[主播] 没事。
[主播] 我不拆了，不拆了，拆这么多塑料瓶子干啥？
[主播] 我的工位上游我那个喝水的杯子里头是水，你把那个拿来。
[主播] 嗯，少用点塑料瓶子。
[主播] 来，喜欢的朋友自己去拍了，北极甜虾。
[主播] 这一盒是139块钱，然后三斤，大概有150只左右。
[主播] 如果大家今天去吃自助餐的话，其实你们应该是见过这个北极甜虾的。
[主播] 它直接等解冻了，蘸一些这个Light Source。
[主播] Light Source翻译成什么？
[主播] 清酱油？
[嘉宾] 不是。
[嘉宾] 有两种酱油，一种炒菜，一种拌菜那种。
[主播] 啊，对对。
[嘉宾] 生抽。
[主播] 对，Light Source叫生抽。
[主播] 你其实可以直接蘸着那个吃。
[主播] 也可以这个蘸着芥末。
[主播] 东北人把那叫辣根，也行。
[主播] 满满的一箱。
[主播] 这个在船上就已经是熟的了啊。
[主播] 看一下啊。
[嘉宾] 我们虾拿回去自然常温化冻就可以直接吃。
[主播] 自然常温化冻。
[主播] 然后收到之后，如果不急着吃的话，你要冻到冰箱里。
[主播] 你再想一想，马上什么？
[主播] 有一个非常重要的球赛就来了，什么？
[主播] 是不是今年？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 今年下半年。
[主播] 世界杯就来了。
[主播] 晚上是不是一群人在家里要吃点东西啊？
[主播] 吃一些什么呢？
[主播] 小龙虾可以吧？
[嘉宾] 可以。
[主播] 喝点啤酒可以吧？
[主播] 然后呢，或者喝一些我们给大家所找的那个杨梅汁可以吧？
[主播] 这个时候冰箱里抓上一盘北极甜虾放在那块。
[嘉宾] 完美。
[主播] 你看是不是就很爽？
[主播] 夏天的热是不是有些燥热？
[主播] 然后你吃这个凉凉的，有一种淡淡的甜味。
[主播] 它来自北大西洋。
[主播] 又很干净。
[主播] 而且腹中全是籽儿。
[主播] 多好啊。
[主播] 就是今年是吧？
[嘉宾] 就今年下半年。
[主播] 我一直有一个愿望，就是什么时候能带我爸去看一次世界杯的球赛。
[主播] 我记得小时候我爸也特别喜欢看球赛。
[主播] 然后呢，他自己一个人看。
[主播] 因为我不太喜欢。
[主播] 我妈也不看。
[主播] 然后呢，而且第二天都还还要有这个繁重的农业劳动。
[主播] 所以他实上其实没有时间的。
[主播] 然后呢，电视机在客厅里。
[主播] 农村的房子呢，可能这个比较
[主播] 重的农业劳动。
[主播] 所以他时常其实没有时间的。
[主播] 然后呢，电视机在客厅里。
[主播] 农村的房子呢，可能这个比较简单一些吧。
[主播] 他晚上在看的时候，他一激动，啊，一喊。
[主播] 我们在卧室里听得非常清楚。
[主播] 他只要一喊，
[主播] 我就能听到我妈妈的门就响了。
[主播] 妈妈就会说，干嘛？
[主播] 杨对劲。
[主播] 就一会我爸电视机就关了，就回去了。
[主播] 然后你再听一会儿。
[主播] 等这个呼噜声起来的时候，门吱一声又开了，我爸又回来了。
[主播] 就他小时候，我们小时候记得他每次想看世界杯的时候，他很半夜很激动，一激动就拍手。
[主播] 然后呢，但是又不敢喊，因为害怕吵醒。
[主播] 对，他第二天呢，肯定很困，但是他还得去地里干活。
[主播] 我记得他特别是，我记得特别深刻。
[主播] 他晚上一个人当时在家里看的时候，那会儿家里小时候条件还好的时候，他还去我们那个村里有个小卖部，买那个一块五一瓶的那种啤酒。
[主播] 不知道你们喝过没，叫啥来著。
[嘉宾] 是不是那个绿色玻璃瓶的，大棒。
[主播] 对对，一块五一瓶。
[主播] 那个其实不怎么好喝。
[主播] 但是他每次到夏天，
[主播] 而且因为那时候家里没有冰箱，他只能从小卖部买的时候，从别人那买得晚一点，他都是等到晚上别人快睡觉的时候才拿回来。
[主播] 或者他白天买了冻在家里，放在家里那个井水里头，然后出来特别凉。
[主播] 他晚上一个人拿一瓶。
[主播] 苦瓜。
[主播] 对，有朋友说苦瓜，真的也是有朋友喝过那个。
[主播] 一块五一瓶，那个其实不好喝，我觉得。
[主播] 但是我爸就特别爱那个。
[主播] 因为当时可能条件也就是那样子。
[主播] 他就每次看那个球赛的时候，我的天哪。
[主播] 如果今年夏天有时间的话，如果你的爸爸或者你的家人，或者你的丈夫，或者你的弟弟，只要是你花时间陪伴了，所以你生命中显得珍贵的那个人。
[主播] 次夏天看一次球赛。
[主播] 熬一次也怕啥。
[主播] 对吧，咱不能每天熬夜。
[主播] 熬一次。
[主播] 就像我突然会在有时候下著大雨，突然说，我们想去看一看这个。
[主播] 想要看一看河，还想要看看湖，下著大雨，撑个伞就去了。
[主播] 回来浑身都淋湿了，但是那个却成为了你印象中。
[主播] 后来觉得非常印象深刻的一次。
[主播] 准备好北京甜虾。
[主播] 准备好他喜欢喝那些小啤酒。
[主播] 和你喜欢吃的小零食。
[主播] 提前约好。
[主播] 或者不约好，突然给他一次惊喜。
[主播] 我相信那个好多年后你们都会记得的。
[主播] 好多年后你一个人在异乡。
[主播] 也没有办法每天去陪他的时候。
[主播] 你仍然会记得那个时刻。
[主播] 衣服。
[主播] 我身上穿这个是吧？
[主播] 补了是吧？
[主播] 补了，喜欢的朋友去拍啊。
[主播] 大家真的喜欢这种衣服吗？
[主播] 因为它带著东方甄选四个字呢。
[嘉宾] 我们刚才刚上来也没多久，已经卖出去1600件。
[嘉宾] 很好看。
[主播] 但是你出于他带著四个字，别人不问你这是什么吗？
[嘉宾] 文化事儿。
[主播] 这穿著有文化吗？
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 是吧？
[嘉宾] 好看。
[主播] 你们觉得真的很好看吗？
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 补了一下马术啊。
[主播] 大家拍的时候要加会员啊。
[主播] 有朋友说今年的世界杯在冬天，看不成是吧？
[主播] 那尴尬的。
[主播] 冬天。
[主播] 世界杯在冬天。
[主播] 想一想，冬天有什么吃的。
[主播] 冬天有啊。
[主播] 冬天，咱们的考场。
[主播] 考场当然可以。
[主播] 冬天去买那种糖炒栗子呀。
[主播] 糖炒栗子好吃吧？
[主播] 炒的特别香。
[主播] 烤的红薯。
[嘉宾] 山水白你有吗？
[嘉宾] 你有看过这个吗？
[嘉宾] 你有穿过这个吗？
[主播] 咱有这个吗？
[主播] 导演你给个进景，啥时候有的？
[嘉宾] 你自己都没有。
[主播] 我自己都没有。
[主播] 然后我们的观众朋友们已经穿上了是吧？
[主播] 山水。
[主播] 山水白。
[主播] 真的就是传统的这种中国色，是吧？
[主播] 显得很有国潮的这种设计。
[主播] 反正我们的图形设计还是挺好的。
[主播] 新时代版的史丹利复合肥。
[主播] 小时候我们家人是真的穿过那种什么什么复合肥的衣服的。
[主播] 是真的有。
[主播] 黄桃罐头，罐头来了。
[主播] 什么东西是吃不腻的？
[嘉宾] 黄桃罐头。
[主播] 第一个是奶奶做的面。
[主播] 我在读初中那会儿，我跟你讲过吧。
[主播] 我在读初中那会儿呢，经常就是两个周才回去一次。
[主播] 而且是周六中午放学，周天的下午晚上回到学校还得上晚自习。
[主播] 没有晚了吗？
[主播] 没有的是吧？
[嘉宾] 这一个杯子可能放不下。
[主播] 所以当时我两星期才回去一次。
[主播] 而且回去的爸爸不在家。
[主播] 爸爸外出打工一年都不在家。
[主播] 妈妈也经常会去在附近找一些力所能及的。
[主播] 一些零工去赚钱。
[主播] 你像我周六中午到家里。
[主播] 其实到家都下午了快。
[主播] 哪有吃的？
[主播] 奶奶知道我那天会回去。
[主播] 所以奶奶一般在周六的时候，他都是特别早的起来去地里干活。
[主播] 然后他到中午的时候一定得赶回去在家里等著。
[主播] 奶奶腰已经很弯了，他很认真的把那个面擀得很薄很薄。
[主播] 我喜欢吃硬一点的面，但是他擀起来就很费劲。
[主播] 他们那个弄好。
[主播] 放在那里。
[主播] 然后等我回去了。
[主播] 这时候拿一些小葱。
[主播] 炒一些鸡蛋。
[主播] 弄得好香好香。
[主播] 然后那个面煮出来。
[主播] 特别简单，好像就放一点点，非常简单的调料。
[主播] 但我不知道为什么那个面的汤那么好喝。
[主播] 那么好吃。
[主播] 每次回去都是呼噜呼噜的吃一碗。
[主播] 然后奶奶说你在家里写作业。
[主播] 她就又去地里干活了。
[主播] 直到很晚很晚的时候妈妈才能回来。
[主播] 可能妈妈在附近干些重体力的活儿吧。
[主播] 所以永远吃不腻的，第一个是奶奶做的那个面。
[主播] 第二个吃不腻的是。
[主播] 是过年时候妈妈炖那个年菜，我不知道你们那有没有炖那个过年菜。
[主播] 有炸的丸子。
[主播] 炸的红薯。
[主播] 然后炸的豆腐。
[主播] 然后海带。
[主播] 然后那些。
[主播] 那些，哇，炖一锅你知道吗？
[主播] 哇，那个肉炖得特别烂，特别香。
[主播] 特别好吃。
[主播] 那是妈妈做的过年菜。
[主播] 还有一个就是发烧的时候姐姐给买的黄桃罐头。
[主播] 冰箱里藏了很多罐。
[嘉宾] 这个好不容易装满了。
[主播] 装满了。
[主播] 这个不是泡那啥的吧？
[嘉宾] 不是。
[主播] 昨天前天你们骗我。
[嘉宾] 不是我，不是我。
[嘉宾] 不是我们，不是我们。
[嘉宾] 我这么爱你，怎么可能骗你？
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 反正现在群东里已经有坏人了。
[主播] 骗我。
[主播] 渣男跟石美儿一样。
[主播] 以前我就不相信男人。
[主播] 经此一次，我再不相信男人。
[主播] 然后我记得。
[主播] 在那个之后，我昨天在看抖音的时候，就有很多朋友跟我私信，东宇辉，你喝的那个就是他们泡过那个洗衣服的那个。
[主播] 还跟我把前后两段视频截了出来。
[主播] 他可能是看的时候会录屏你知道吗？
[主播] 很多朋友看我们会录屏的。
[主播] 反正录了出来，还给我发过来。
[主播] 你看就一样。
[主播] 再不相信这些人了。
[主播] 黄桃罐头啊。
[主播] 它是整个大块的。
[主播] 是半个的。
[主播] 有的那种是四分之一的。
[主播] 而且是软塌塌的。
[主播] 这个是脆的。
[嘉宾] 你真的应该很喜欢吃，每次上来的时候都起码吃两个。
[主播] 每次上来的时候我都吃。
[嘉宾] 是脆的吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 脆的。
[主播] 我喜欢吃脆的。
[主播] 很有味道。
[嘉宾] 小时候没有胃口就喜欢吃这种。
[主播] 那看来我们有很相似的生活经历。
[主播] 小时候。
[主播] 我我跟你讲过。
[主播] 我当时吃这个黄桃罐头第一次。
[主播] 是我在高一升高二那年把腿摔断了。
[主播] 在医院住著呢。
[主播] 做完手术。
[主播] 我做手术还抗麻呢。
[主播] 我们家人好像有一点遗传的抗麻药。
[主播] 反正我记得打了麻药两次我还有感觉。
[主播] 但最后就那样做了。
[主播] 疼晕了我。
[主播] 我能感觉到电钻在腿上。
[主播] 拧了钉子。
[主播] 后来我在恢复的时候就特别瘦。
[主播] 吃不下去，没有胃口。
[主播] 躺那也不动。
[主播] 本来饭量就差了。
[主播] 医生说得让孩子吃。
[主播] 但是我又真的什么都不想吃。
[主播] 最后姐姐实在不行。
[主播] 姐姐说你你随便想吃什么我给你买。
[主播] 你想吃辣条不？
[主播] 小时候喜欢吃辣条吗？
[主播] 你随便吃一点。
[主播] 你喜欢吃辣条不？
[主播] 不想吃了。
[主播] 你小时候不是喜欢吃烤火腿肠吗？
[主播] 给你买火腿肠去。
[主播] 不想吃了。
[主播] 姐突然你想不想吃罐头？
[主播] 我说想吃。
[主播] 因为我给你讲过有一年过年走亲戚。
[主播] 小时候走亲戚是要提那个各种各样的。
[主播] 罐头。
[主播] 奶啊，罐头啊，肉啊，酒啊那些。
[主播] 我记得就有一次走路上我甩一个袋子。
[主播] 崩一下摔碎了。
[主播] 但是是裂了。
[主播] 不是把底摔破了，跟酒瓶撞裂了。
[主播] 然后呢，就流出来。
[主播] 吓一跳，我爸赶快过来把那个倒掉。
[主播] 水倒掉。
[主播] 然后我跟姐姐大冬天的蹲在路边。
[主播] 大年出来走亲戚的路上。
[主播] 我们俩把那个罐那个橘子的罐头就分完了。
[主播] 特别好喝，特别好吃。
[主播] 小时候贪吃嘛。
[主播] 然后姐姐说罐头。
[主播] 我说可以可以可以，特别想吃的罐头。
[主播] 然后姐姐就真的出去买。
[主播] 但是没有找到那个橘子的罐头。
[主播] 姐姐没有找到。
[主播] 姐姐回来买了黄桃的罐头。
[主播] 那是我住院那几天里头吃的第一次饭。
[主播] 就是吃的罐头。
[主播] 吃完之后我发现还是姐姐懂我。
[主播] 她知道你喜欢吃什么。
[主播] 后来每次身体不舒服的时候就想吃罐头。
[主播] 因为它没有治病的作用。
[主播] 必须澄清啊。
[主播] 发烧的时候没有任何治病的作用。
[主播] 但你就是想吃。
[主播] 就像你受伤的时候想要被安慰。
[主播] 做错的想要被宽容。
[主播] 误会的想要被理解一样。
[主播] 在逆境中想要被尊重一样。
[主播] 它是一种心理需求。
[主播] 而不是一种生理需求。
[嘉宾] 罐头只有1000单是吧？
[主播] 我姐姐是世界上最好的姐姐了。
[主播] 我的意思是我我的世界里。
[主播] 来，千层饼啊。
[主播] 同关肉夹馍的饼。
[主播] 咱这里头是加了什么？
[嘉宾] 你猜。
[主播] 加了鸡蛋。
[主播] 还有午餐火腿肉吗？
[嘉宾] 宣子肉。
[嘉宾] 加了这个。
[主播] 哎哟。
[主播] 怎么这么会做呢？
[主播] 这是同关肉夹馍的那种饼啊。
[主播] 但是因为那个肉没有办法给你送。
[主播] 因为那个肉它如果卤好了，里头其实是有盐的。
[主播] 盐放的时间久了，对你身体不太好。
[主播] 所以我就不卖那肉了。
[主播] 只有这个饼。
[主播] 这个饼特别酥。
[主播] 你在锅里煎一下。
[主播] 烤箱电饼铛都可以。
[主播] 你看。
[主播] 它是酥的可以掉层的这种。
[主播] 同关肉夹馍这就是它的一个特点。
[主播] 我我们一般同关的当地人在外面是很少吃肉夹馍的。
[主播] 因为饼都不讲究。
[主播] 你的饼子都不讲究，你那肉味道能独得有多地道。
[主播] 但这个饼就很地道。
[主播] 因为就是我们当地的一个企业去生产的。
[主播] 就是我在被大家关注之后。
[主播] 特别想为老家能做一些事情。
[主播] 当地政府也在联系我。
[主播] 然后呢，当地很多的企业也在联系我。
[主播] 我们经过了层层的筛选。
[主播] 从饼子的口感制作工艺。
[主播] 售后的满意度评分上。
[主播] 等等选了这一家。
[主播] 我还了解过他们找的都是当地的一些人。
[主播] 所以对于当地的就业也是有些帮助的。
[主播] 还是挺开心的，能替他们出一些力。
[主播] 然后呢，当然后来紧接著陕西省。
[主播] 其实更早的是陕西省省委上的一些领导联系我。
[主播] 所以后来敲定了这个随后有时间的去陕西直播一次。
[主播] 把陕西的农产品推荐给大家。
[主播] 然后当然今天给大家说的也有这个黑龙江的也联系了我们。
[主播] 江苏的还有新疆的。
[主播] 咱也会去新疆的。
[嘉宾] 好奇。
[主播] 好奇对吗？
[主播] 咱会去新疆。
[主播] 然后呢，现在已经找了他们提前准备了很多品种农产品，已经在对了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我们预计，本来预计第一个去应该是陕西。
[主播] 但是现在西安最近不是要带口罩吗？
[主播] 所以可能第一个要去的就是黑龙江了。
[主播] 很期待吧？
[嘉宾] 很期待。
[主播] 黑龙江就是最靠北了，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 漠河。
[主播] 漠河大家知道就已经在特别北了。
[主播] 你们听过那个漠河舞厅对吧？
[主播] 听过吧？
[主播] 漠河的旁边是什么你知道吗？
[主播] 我给你画一下。
[主播] 那个鸡头画的不是特别准确啊。
[主播] 鸡头大概是这个样子。
[主播] 这块是漠河。
[主播] 漠河的旁边是塔河。
[主播] 塔河是哪不知道吧？
[主播] 咱之前给大家推荐过一本书叫做额尔古纳河右岸。
[主播] 它的作者是谁？
[嘉宾] 迟子建老师。
[主播] 迟子建老师就是塔河人。
[主播] 咱这个蓝莓原浆今年还有吗？
[嘉宾] 卖光了。
[主播] 蓝莓原浆就是在塔河这里生产的。
[主播] 这里就是大兴安岭的原始森林呢。
[主播] 现在想起来没有？
[嘉宾] 想起来了。
[主播] 在原始森林里。
[主播] 山间的精灵啊。
[主播] 像散落在人间的星河。
[主播] 多浪漫。
[主播] 且不说吃了，我听著就觉得美。
[主播] 已经到了中国最北了都。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 朋友说黑龙江现在凉快得很。
[主播] 好期待啊。
[主播] 这个黄桃罐头差不多了。
[主播] 同关千层饼现在还有多少单，导演？
[嘉宾] 还有1100单。
[主播] 想吃的朋友大家可以试一下啊。
[主播] 我们这里给大家展示的其中一种吃法。
[主播] 当然这个阿姨真的可能很心疼我们。
[主播] 叫桌上。
[嘉宾] 他给你加了好多宣子肉。
[主播] 他这个午餐肉和鸡蛋。
[主播] 加的真是太满了。
[主播] 大家平时在家里可以炒一些其他的菜也行。
[主播] 用孜然炒个牛肉。
[主播] 青椒孜然牛肉也炒给他会加也特别舒服。
[主播] 真酥。
[主播] 你听见咬的声音了吗？
[嘉宾] 我已经听见了。
[主播] 很酥。
[主播] 我给你们讲过没？
[主播] 就在同关那么小的县城里头，肉夹馍还分为几种不同的门派。
[主播] 他也会让您一些原本糊涂的人。
[主播] 最终找到生命真正的答案。
[主播] 时间是一个魔法师。
[主播] 魔法师只需要特别简单的东西。
[主播] 就是盐。
[主播] 就可以。
[主播] 魔法师 is a versatile。
[主播] 它会在你。
[主播] 跋山涉水。
[主播] 流汗花。
[主播] 非常细腻。
[主播] is a versatile performer。
[主播] flies。
[主播] much。
[主播] walks。
[主播] It tells the answer。
[主播] the pressure。
[主播] 时间从来不语。
[主播] 却回答了这就是时间给你的惊喜。
[主播] 黑猪后腿的午餐肉。
[主播] 黑猪后腿抹上盐，挂在山洞里做成的火腿午餐肉。
[主播] 做成的火腿放在盒子里。
[主播] 肉的含量在90%以上。
[主播] 看得见的肉颗粒。
[主播] 切成厚片煎一下。
[主播] 特别香。
[主播] 你看这种食物本身就充满了浪漫。
[主播] 对吧？
[嘉宾] 切一个看。
[主播] 我的天。
[主播] 来导演给个进景，让大家看一下这里头的瘦肉。
[主播] 时间从来不语。
[主播] 却回答了你一切问题。
[主播] Time is a versatile performer。
[主播] It's never makes any noise。
[主播] 从来不发出任何的噪音。
[主播] but it answers all the questions。
[主播] 它就回答了所有问题。
[主播] 45块三罐。
[主播] 这个价格换一个地方你应该是找不到的。
[主播] 因为这是新东方当时选择转型做农业之后。
[主播] 这家企业当时愿意帮我们。
[主播] 给了我们一个很少能找到的价格。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 虽然可能当时他们也没有抱特别大的希望。
[主播] 像找了一个看起来不怎么样的年轻人。
[主播] 压注在这个年轻人身上一样。
[主播] 这个世界上看起来最徒劳无功的事情。
[主播] 就是陪一个年轻人成长。
[主播] 但你相信年轻人不会让你失望的。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 这个午餐肉后来在我们直播间里曾经多次卖到过。
[主播] 抖音这个销售午餐肉罐头榜的。
[主播] 这个位置很长时间。
[主播] 因为在当时愿意给我们那么好的诚意和配合。
[主播] 还挺动人的。
[主播] 坦诚来说不是给我们。
[主播] 是给俞老师的。
[嘉宾] 啊？
[嘉宾] 我们考场是猪肉。
[主播] 这个不是黑猪是吧？
[主播] OK。
[嘉宾] 它的配料就是猪肉和宣威火腿。
[主播] 猪肉火腿。
[嘉宾] 主要是宣威火腿。
[主播] 宣威火腿是吧？
[主播] 宣威火腿不是说是黑猪吗？
[主播] 我记得他们说是。
[主播] 你问一下。
[嘉宾] 我问一下。
[主播] 就其他的这里头是除了火腿还有正常的普通的猪肉。
[主播] 普通的猪肉是。
[主播] 这个罐如果全是宣威火腿。
[主播] 那我的天，别说45了。
[主播] 你145你买不来吗？
[主播] 就是三罐的话。
[主播] 整个正常的这火腿价格是非常高的。
[主播] 大家能看到这里头这个有两种。
[主播] 导演你给个进景看一下。
[主播] 第一种是这种小的块看到没？
[主播] 这种小的块其实就是那个火腿了。
[主播] 旁边白色的这个就是正常的黑猪，这个正常的猪肉了啊。
[主播] 别冲了行不行？
[主播] 大家又开始冲赞，冲啥赞吗？
[主播] 别冲了啊。
[主播] 听话。
[主播] 行不行？
[嘉宾] 他觉得这个都不够卖。
[嘉宾] 我们去卖。
[主播] 大家又开始冲赞冲杀赞吗？
[主播] 别冲了啊，听话。
[主播] 行不行？
[嘉宾] 我觉得这个都不够卖，我们今天有3万的库存，就卖太少了。
[主播] 今天3万单都卖光了是吧？
[嘉宾] 还剩3000单了。
[主播] 3万单卖了3000单。
[嘉宾] 还剩3000单。
[主播] 挺好的，反正好东西都卖一些。
[主播] 大家尝一尝，反正我当时在吃完之后，我就给我的家人买了一单，我也给我先的朋友买了一单，因为我跟我我跟你讲，我先那个朋友。
[主播] 我每次都是在感觉人生很迷茫的时候，我就会去找他。
[主播] 我其实平常我们俩没有太多的时间在一起做无聊社交，没有。
[主播] 我我很迷茫的时候去找找他。
[主播] 他很迷茫的时候他就约我。
[主播] 其实有时候自己也是胡说八道，或者他说的也不一定都对。
[主播] 但是有时候你听别人的解释，却能找到自己内心的答案。
[主播] 很多时候都是，他讲他的故事，你却听到了你的回答。
[主播] 想著想著就明白了。
[主播] 我们还有一种喜欢做的就是开车在西安风峪口，一直到山里头。
[主播] 到山顶的时候有一个秦岭和长，黄河和长江的分界线。
[主播] 在山顶。
[主播] 吹一吹山风，瞬间就清醒了，什么都想明白了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 尤其是他过去这一年里头，我我不是曾经过去这半年里头很痛苦吗？
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 我就找他诉苦。
[主播] 然后他做的生意，因为很长时间里头，可能最近一两年大家生意都因为很多原因，很难很难的时候，他也会找我诉苦。
[主播] 互相诉苦。
[主播] 然后呢，但是喝酒的时候你得吃点吗？
[主播] 所以当时这个还挺好吃的。
[主播] 可以当下酒菜，余老师喜欢拿它当下酒菜。
[主播] 同关肉夹馍没了是吧？这个饼子没了？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 没了啊。
[嘉宾] 咱们肉给大家看。
[主播] 给大家看一下啊。
[主播] 能看到明显的肉的颗粒，所以嚼的时候有一种大口的嚼瘦肉的那种感觉。
[主播] 松软。
[主播] 然后有香气扑鼻。
[主播] 这个香气就是来自于神奇的魔法师时间。
[主播] 时间会给所有人答案。
[主播] 时间会抚平所有的伤痛。
[主播] 时间也会淡化所有的回忆。
[主播] 时间常常能够让你知道什么是真正重要的东西。
[主播] 但时间也会偶尔褪去你一时的激情，让你有的时候判断不准，好像有些东西对你不再重要了。
[主播] 时间会让你做正确的决定。
[主播] 时间也常常会误导你做出错误的选择题。
[主播] 你能听懂我说什么，对吧？
[主播] 不要对那些东西习以为常啊。
[主播] 来。
[主播] 一面。
[主播] Pasta。
[嘉宾] 咖喱味的。
[主播] 我们用的是筷子，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对，筷子就筷子。
[主播] 算了，我就用筷子吃，管我呢。
[主播] 中体为学，西体为用嘛。
[主播] 听过吧？
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 就用筷子吃也行。
[主播] 这种应该让顿顿来吃。
[主播] 因为我跟石明这种大老粗去吃的话，可能就是蹲在地上，剥个蒜，就没有太多的美感了。
[嘉宾] 昨天石明剥了蒜吃了。
[主播] 剥了蒜吃了。
[主播] 哈哈。
[主播] 好。
[嘉宾] 现在带货的球越来越高了。
[主播] 说我要吃蒜。
[嘉宾] 立马就给拿来了。
[主播] 啊，要蒜就给蒜。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我有一次点了一个点外卖，点了一个面，因为我在附近实在找不到好吃的面。
[主播] 特别想吃，所以我就点了一份外卖。
[主播] 然后我给那个店家备注，我说你能不能不要用纸盒子？
[主播] 不要用塑料盒子，给我换个纸盒子。
[主播] 店家说没有。
[主播] 过了会他说有能加加钱。
[主播] 我说加多少钱？他说加两块，我说可以可以，你加吧。
[主播] 然后都都说完了，他说做好了，然后我又要打电话，我说你能不能给我加一个蒜？
[主播] 店家说这么麻烦，挣你这一单钱。
[主播] 最后送过来的时候真的有一个蒜，我的天啊，我在办公室。
[主播] 吃完之后又不好意思。
[嘉宾] 不敢说话。
[主播] 其实咱如果从这往前走，后来我发现一个，从这往前走是有个牛肉面的。
[主播] 就它挺好吃的。
[主播] 一定要把那个辣辣子油多放一些，我的天，那个汤真香，真好喝。
[嘉宾] 你之前跟视频合租的时候，你们会自己在家里做这种东西吗？其实很简单。
[主播] 我给他做过好多次面呢。
[主播] 但是做的不是这个面，当时我那会太穷了，我那会买不起这个面。
[主播] 真的，109六盒，一盒算上十多块钱。
[主播] 我们当时租的小区门口有个卖菜的地方，我买一份面是4块钱。
[主播] 我再买一些菠菜。
[主播] 然后。
[嘉宾] 清水煮啊。
[主播] 煮完了之后蒜剁碎，然后放上那个辣椒面，油一泼，倒上其他的。
[主播] 老陕吃面就是那个，你知道吗？
[主播] 当然我也给他做过臊子面，就拿肉炒的那个臊子。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 他你还吃。
[主播] 他吃过，他吃过很多次呢，虽然他现在不承认了。
[嘉宾] 那那这个面你可以吃吗？就是不用一个做吗？
[主播] 这很好做的。
[主播] 其实它很好做，就是这个只需要水一煮就行了，然后这个酱料因为里头都有。
[主播] 它其实制作非常容易。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 它很精致。
[嘉宾] 里面有一个制作的。
[主播] 它有制作指南的，是。
[嘉宾] 这个哎，盒里盒里。
[主播] 开个给大家看一下啊。
[嘉宾] 我们吃吧。
[主播] 嗯。
[嘉宾] 我我家做了，我煮这个面就花了15分钟，就完了。
[主播] 我们都，我们都买过，我们现在。
[主播] 香草橄榄油包。
[主播] 干酪撒粉，就是上面撒白色那个东西。
[主播] 然后这个是海盐。
[嘉宾] 海盐跟橄榄油是跟这个面一块煮的。
[主播] 啊，海盐和橄榄油，这两个是煮的时候要放到汤里头。
[嘉宾] 为了防止它不粘，有味道。
[主播] 煮15分钟。
[主播] 嗯，你知道如果煮汤里头放点油的优点是什么吗？
[嘉宾] 不粘面是不是？
[主播] 第一个是不粘连，第二个主要的优点是不会锅一出来。
[主播] 第三个煮的肉。
[主播] 这个面会更香。
[主播] 你知道有的人蒸米饭或者煮白粥的时候里头会倒一点点油吗？
[主播] 第一点油第一个原因就是它不会一直溢出来。
[主播] 第二就是饭会更香一些。
[嘉宾] 橄榄油可以那么用。
[主播] 可以。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 然后还有黑胡椒粉。
[主播] 呃，欧芹碎，就是上面撒那个绿色的。
[主播] 然后这个是面，煮15分钟就行了，是吧？
[主播] 这个是酱，所以它其实非常简单。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 非常简单。
[主播] 如果你自己回到家里，或者你像我们这种在外务工人员。
[主播] 其实你可能需要这个。
[主播] 最美的不是下雨天，而是与你一起躲过雨的屋檐。
[主播] 最美的也不是七月天，是七月天你给他煮的那碗一面。
[主播] 对吧？
[主播] 点外卖，是不是会点？
[主播] 煮子面试试。
[嘉宾] 这个面是外卖的店。
[嘉宾] 太好点了。
[主播] 那当然，那当然。
[主播] 这个算下一包才十来块钱，是吧？
[嘉宾] 八。
[主播] 你要是外卖能点到这个品质，那至少价格应该在三倍了。
[嘉宾] 它肉里面真的很多。
[主播] 肉很多是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己拍啊，丰俭由人。
[主播] 按需购买，理性消费。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 我生怕你在我们直播间一冲动把钱花多了。
[主播] 所以我一直提醒你，一直提醒你。
[主播] 我一直控制著你花钱，最后你买的应该都是真的自己需要的。
[主播] 如果我鼓励你去买的话，可能会买到一些你不需要的。
[主播] 阳山水蜜桃是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 我都已经啃了半个了在这。
[主播] 哇，这个。
[嘉宾] 你那个是脆的，我这个是软的，放时间长了。
[主播] 确实我是真的第一次吃，虽然我以前听过阳山水蜜桃。
[嘉宾] 你没有买过吗？
[主播] 买，但是这几天你没给我吃啊。
[嘉宾] 不好意思。
[嘉宾] 这很好吃。
[主播] 它口感真的不一样。
[主播] 阳山水蜜桃如果大家听过的话，它是很知名的那块水蜜桃。
[主播] 但坦诚来说价格高。
[主播] 都很大。
[嘉宾] 我们今天买的这个是小规格的。
[嘉宾] 是八粒装的。
[主播] 八粒装的。
[嘉宾] 单果是五到六两的。
[主播] 单果五到六两。
[主播] 你知道水蜜桃如果熟透了，这个果肉也会变成紫色吗？
[主播] 我们家院子就有个桃树。
[嘉宾] 不好意思，给大家看一下我啃了半个的。
[嘉宾] 它这是熟透了的，就是。
[主播] 我们的导演在旁边也在啃桃。
[主播] 朋友说要放软的更好吃是吧？
[嘉宾] 对，我觉得放放软了也很好吃。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 喜欢吃再买啊。
[主播] 当然它确实口感跟普通的桃能吃出来差异。
[主播] 看你自己是否有这个消费需求。
[主播] 你如果就想尝一尝。
[主播] 我来这人世间不就是想看一看太阳怎么升？
[主播] 花怎么开？
[主播] 水怎么流？
[主播] 我不是想读几本深刻的书，遇见一两个志同道合的朋友，尝一些有特色的食物。
[主播] 那你可以买。
[主播] 如果你觉得说我们家楼下三块也一样，四块也一样，我不想买，那就不买，啊。
[主播] 哇，这个是烤的吗？
[嘉宾] 对，烤的。
[主播] 你看这个是烤出来这个糖的。
[主播] 导演给个近景看一下。
[主播] 红薯能烤出来这糖，就说明它真的很甜了。
[嘉宾] 对。
[嘉宾] 到手是五斤，而且是已糖化了的。
[主播] 已经糖化了，到手五斤是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 这个季节按道理来说应该已经没有红薯了。
[嘉宾] 可能是它在成熟的时候保存了很久。
[主播] 或者它可能是其他大棚里头种的。
[主播] 因为你知道。
[嘉宾] 这个是海南产的，其实海南这个季节。
[主播] 啊，海南产的，OK。
[主播] 北方的红薯一般是就是收收完玉米了就收它。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 10月中下旬。
[嘉宾] 我妈今年就中了。
[主播] 是吧？
[主播] 然后吃不完会放在这个菜窖里或者红薯窖里。
[主播] 然后一直可以吃到第二年，基本上4月中旬就开始慢慢就没了，到五一那会红薯就放不住了，都坏了都。
[主播] 不吃了，一吃一直没没法说话了。
[嘉宾] 给给大家看一下，然后等会我们去吃。
[主播] 红薯啊。
[嘉宾] 主要是我们想吃。
[主播] 哇。
[主播] 哇，这个香气。
[主播] 来给，咱们俩分吧。
[嘉宾] 谢谢。
[主播] 给，这个也给你。
[主播] 你知道以前上高中那会，学校门口冬天空气干冷，阳光很刺眼，但是一点都不热。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 阳光很刺眼，但是一点都不热。
[主播] 学校门口有一个大叔，带着一个毛衣织的帽子，这个毛线织的帽子。
[主播] 然后呢，总是站在学校墙边晒著太阳，烤的红薯飘散的香味。
[嘉宾] 对，之前我。
[主播] 因为你知道普通的红薯和能烤红薯的这种。
[主播] 我一周只敢吃那么一两次，没没没钱吃饭了。
[主播] 生活费其实很紧张。
[主播] 每次在吃的时候都要让叔叔帮我多挑几次。
[主播] 要那种已经烤软的，而不是捏软的。
[嘉宾] 里面已经化了油的。
[主播] 哎，他为了卖的快些，他有的是一直捏捏，之后捏软，其实那种并不好吃。
[主播] 要自己流出油的那种，皮已经皱巴巴的。
[主播] 水分仿佛都被蒸发的差不多了。
[主播] 一定会挑到最好的那个。
[主播] 然后冒著香气藏在袖子里，烫乎乎的放在口袋里，手摸著那个像揣著一个惊喜一样。
[主播] 像怀里藏著一个想要告诉你的秘密一样。
[嘉宾] 再我再尝一下大家。
[主播] 在我偷吃之前再给大家看一眼。
[主播] 哇，你看这个。
[嘉宾] 哇。
[嘉宾] 我刚刚了一下手上其实已经有那个糖油了。
[主播] 对，每次都要挑半天，挑的嘴满意一个。
[主播] 一开始吃的时候到教室里一定要把那个分的尝一口。
[主播] 后来。
[主播] 还攒了好长时间，买了个特别大的。
[主播] 很认真的送给了他。
[主播] 但是他好像没有那么惊喜。
[嘉宾] 现在送我，我很惊喜。
[嘉宾] 啊，你已经送我了，它真的很甜。
[主播] 对。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我当时觉得烤红薯对男生来说是最好吃的东西。
[主播] 特别有心意的东西。
[主播] 你想啊。
[主播] 冰冷的冬天，你怀里揣著一个。
[主播] 散著的烤红薯。
[主播] 像不像心里藏了一个很久的秘密要告诉他一样？
[主播] 像吧？
[主播] 结果他不喜欢。
[主播] 转手就送给了别人。
[主播] 哎，我就再不买了。
[主播] 哈哈。
[主播] 喜欢的朋友自己拍啊。
[主播] 朋友们这是什么红薯？
[主播] 海南千野新石，这好像是一个很特色的红薯，对吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 我从它包装都看出来。
[主播] OK。
[主播] 你看这个标签。
[嘉宾] 我们前几天买的朋友其实已经收到了。
[主播] So according to the instructions, I do believe this is special sweet potato.
[主播] Imported to like several countries in Europe.
[主播] Clean.
[主播] 烤红薯得这种长一些的，对，因为它容易熟。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 如果都是这种粗短的，其实不太容易熟的，反而。
[主播] 有时候外表都都干了，里头还是生的。
[主播] 小时候吃烤红薯。
[主播] 我记得我妈做完饭那个灶。
[主播] 锅灶里头有热的灰。
[嘉宾] 埋一个。
[主播] 我爸就会洗几个，洗干净，埋在里头。
[主播] 然后等吃完饭了，我爸就会偷偷拿出来，上面烧的黑乎乎的，手上拿一圈是灰。
[主播] 我跟我弟蹲在，还有我姐，蹲在我们家门口。
[主播] 做饭需要大火。
[主播] 但是火太大，会把我埋的红薯给烧烧坏。
[主播] 我爸就把火弄得小，结果煮出。
[主播] 妈妈生气了。
[主播] 别捣乱了。
[主播] 我爸每次只能偷偷的弄。
[主播] 冬天如果有机会回农村老家，他就会在炉子里。
[主播] 直到现在北方人是很多地方要靠煤炉去取暖，因为农村嘛，没有天然气。
[主播] 靠煤炉去暖。
[主播] 会在煤炉最上面那一层里头埋上很多的，偷偷的藏很多的红薯。
[主播] 火不能太大。
[主播] 太大了就黑了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 小火其实弄出来那个更好吃。
[主播] 然后呢，空气里全是，一开始全是煤炉的味道。
[主播] 然后过一会就飘出来了红薯那个香味，你走在院子你就能闻得到。
[主播] 干净的天空。
[主播] 清冷的空气。
[主播] 飘著红薯的香味。
[主播] 像是藏在心里很久的秘密，想要告诉你。
[主播] 来，哇。
[嘉宾] 还有500单了。
[主播] 啊？
[主播] 咋了？
[主播] 朋友说我童年也有这样的回忆，真的是。
[嘉宾] 红薯还有300单了。
[主播] 啥？6.9亿。
[嘉宾] 点赞。
[主播] 点赞已经6.9亿了。
[嘉宾] 他们想冲6.9亿。
[主播] 啊。
[嘉宾] 已经6.3亿了。
[主播] 别冲了，清还快。
[主播] 但这个红薯是不是比较贵啊？
[嘉宾] 大概十多块钱。
[主播] 那就是真的挺贵的。
[主播] 理性购物，好吧？
[嘉宾] 是这个时间超市卖的话也是十多块钱。
[主播] 好吃是真好吃，但是贵是真贵。
[主播] 我是重度用户。
[嘉宾] 大家可以理性消费。
[主播] 理性消费。
[主播] 当然你要是如果十块一斤的红薯对你来说是很正常的话，丰俭由人嘛，对吧？
[主播] 不能要求大家跟我一样过苦日子。
[主播] 但是如果说你觉得它太贵，你就不买的就行了。
[嘉宾] 已经九块多了。
[嘉宾] 45块钱一斤。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我刚讲那个只是想让你回想起那种惊喜。
[主播] 你不一定非要买。
[主播] 你不一定现在吃啊。
[主播] 你可以等到今年的红薯上市的时候。
[嘉宾] 10月份就有了。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 然后呢，回家给你自己烤。
[主播] 如果家里有烤箱可以烤不？也可以。
[嘉宾] 空气炸锅也可以。
[主播] 如果你想吃那种流糖油的，那怎么办？
[嘉宾] 包著锡纸。
[嘉宾] 炉子锡纸烤。
[主播] 得用锡纸烤。
[主播] 它糖油就能流出来。
[主播] 朋友说。
[主播] 今晚有高洁丝吗？
[主播] 高洁丝是。
[嘉宾] 你你看弹幕。
[嘉宾] 弹幕。
[主播] 我昨天刚知道。
[主播] 啥？
[嘉宾] 你没有必要知道。
[嘉宾] 继续。
[主播] 咱没有是吧？
[嘉宾] 这个我真解释不了。
[嘉宾] 我昨天也刚知道。
[嘉宾] 但是。
[主播] 牛奶啊。
[主播] 这个牛奶卖完了之后能让我讲一会书不？
[嘉宾] 可以啊。
[主播] 托伦苏。
[主播] 纯真。
[主播] 啊，两盒牛奶加一盒酸奶，对吧？
[嘉宾] 咱们好久没上过，最近一直有朋友在要新药的。
[主播] 三盒一共34小盒，34小盒114。
[主播] 一盒三块多。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 啊，对不起对不起，我不是故意的。
[主播] 我我我我我看见大家说的了，我不是我真不知道那个是啥。
[嘉宾] 他也不知道。
[嘉宾] 他如此默契都不知道。
[主播] 那我知道了，知道了，看你说了。
[主播] 朋友说董宇辉你都卖不过顿顿。
[主播] 没事没事。
[主播] 挣这些干嘛？
[主播] 大家有需求就买，啊。
[主播] 没事没事。
[主播] 挣这些干嘛。
[主播] 大家有需求就买。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 牛奶酸奶一瓶三块多，应该是挺便宜的，坦诚来说。
[主播] 因为正常如果在楼下便利店买这一盒是六块五。
[嘉宾] 六块五。
[主播] 是六块五。
[主播] 这个比另外一个品牌的那个呃旗间的牛奶贵个五毛钱。
[主播] 你们有没有注意吧？
[主播] 楼下便利店的买的。
[嘉宾] 对，因为我从门这买，所以我们没有关注过它。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 朋友东西会你你会卖那个吗？对不起，我真的不会卖。
[主播] 我不知道咋卖。
[主播] 所以这就体现了。
[主播] 其实顿顿比我懂的更多呀。
[主播] 知识盲区。
[主播] 我们之前有一段时间，我跟他说过，之前有一段时间我们直播间真的，那段时间太惨了，太难了。挣扎一天卖不了多少钱。直播间动动人数从，有一段时间上上千，现在上三千了，感觉哎呀，是不是苦日子要到头了，结果又掉掉破一千了。剩七八百人了。就窘迫到自己不知道咋办了，还在复盘，复盘的时候生怕自己不够坦诚批评，找不到原因，互相辱骂羞辱那种。对彼此非常狠。你们没有是吧？
[嘉宾] 奇怪。
[主播] 就。
[嘉宾] 我们没有。
[嘉宾] 怎么可能没有？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 听懂了。
[主播] 但是还是没用，反正人数就是少。
[主播] 然后呢，实在没有办法了。
[主播] 他们说交易额多了，你直播间的这个人数就会高。
[主播] 我们还卖过一个星期左右的化妆品。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 但是现在如果菜能卖动，我还是会把主力放在卖菜上，卖吃的上。
[主播] 因为卖那个更懂的人，有更多更懂的人，那个可能不需要我们。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 我也不懂，我给大家讲不好。
[主播] 只要是让你开心的，能够好好生活的东西，我认为都是有意义的。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 然后呢。
[主播] 当时就特别尬。
[主播] 我每次把那个叫海蓝之家，海蓝。
[嘉宾] 海蓝之家。
[主播] 海蓝，海洋之谜吧。
[主播] 海蓝。
[嘉宾] 不说海蓝之家。
[主播] 不，他告诉是海洋之谜。
[主播] 卖的是真尴尬呀，我也不知道咋讲。
[主播] 这是。
[主播] 牛奶是六月份的。
[嘉宾] 保持期也是六个月。
[主播] 保持期都是六个月。
[主播] 这俩都是六月份的，对吧？
[主播] OK，导演。
[主播] 确定吗？
[嘉宾] 确定。
[主播] 酸奶和纯奶都是六月份的奶啊。
[嘉宾] 是的。
[主播] 好。
[主播] 那就不是临期，请你放心啊。
[嘉宾] 因为我们缺货很久了，所以。
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 对，因为前段时间卖断货的，你想都断货了，说明没有库存了。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 许渊冲老师的书有吗？
[主播] 导演，来上一下。
[嘉宾] 有。
[主播] 让我说会废话吧。
[主播] 我前几天是不是已经讲过李白了？
[主播] 我好像也说过杜甫的是吧？
[嘉宾] 对。
[主播] 王维我说过的没？
[主播] 我好像也说过王维的是吧？
[主播] 摩羯是。
[主播] 摩羯居士。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 王维是信佛的。
[主播] 后人对王维的评价，诗中有画，画中有诗。
[主播] 王维跟李白一样，都是701年出生的。
[主播] 王维是山西。
[主播] 永济人。
[主播] 杨贵妃也是山西永济人。
[主播] 然后呢。
[主播] 那就今天讲白居易吧。
[主播] 导演我问你，白居易早还是杜甫早？
[嘉宾] 白居易。
[主播] 白居易早是吧？
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 白居易非常经典的一个作品叫。
[主播] 我给你提句啊，就杨家有女初长成，养在深闺人不知。
[主播] 什么？
[嘉宾] 长恨歌。
[主播] 长恨歌说的是谁？
[主播] 唐玄宗杨贵妃对吧？
[嘉宾] 杨贵妃。
[主播] 唐玄宗杨贵妃的时候发生了一个非常重要的这个事件叫做安史之乱对吧？
[主播] 安史之乱逃难的过程中，杜甫是不是被叛军抓住了，带回了长安？
[主播] 所以杜甫是不是那个时代的人？
[主播] 那你想白居易都后来写诗记住了这个事情了，白居易能是那个时代的人吗？
[主播] 再问你一遍，谁早？
[嘉宾] 杜甫。
[主播] 杜甫早。
[主播] 啊。
[主播] 我们刚提这几个人里头，李白跟王维都是701年生人。
[主播] 然后比他们稍微小一点点的是杜甫。
[主播] 杜甫之后的才是白居易。
[主播] 嗯。
[主播] 杜甫跟白居易有没有什么关系啊？
[主播] 有没有？
[主播] 这里头都是徐老师的照片，徐老师的真帅年轻时候。
[主播] 不知道是吧？
[主播] 有关系，你听我跟你讲啊。
[嘉宾] 好。
[主播] 白居易的祖籍在哪？
[主播] 在山西。
[嘉宾] 山西。
[主播] 这个你知道是吧？
[嘉宾] 对，山西太原的。
[主播] 山西太原人。
[主播] 在白居易的爷爷的父亲那一代，那个叫什么？应该叫曾祖父是吧？
[嘉宾] 嗯。
[主播] 从那一代人，他们住在了哪里呢？
[主播] 不知道咋念。
[主播] 这个就是现在渭南临渭区。
[嘉宾] 河南吗？
[主播] 渭南临渭区。
[主播] 渭南。
[主播] 渭南在哪？
[主播] 你在河南。